हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। तो प्लीज टेल मी सबको मेरी
आवाज सुनाई दे रही है?
आई एम ऑडिबल एवरीवन।
चैट में बताइए जल्दी से कि सबको मेरी आवाज
सुनाई दे रही है या नहीं सुनाई दे रही?
प्लीज टेल मी।
ओके।
थैंक यू।
ओके सभी लोग रेडी हैं आज की क्लास के लिए
तो
दो मिनट का टाइम लेते हैं बाकी स्टूडेंट्स
को आने के लिए ज्वाइन होने के लिए तब तक
के लिए प्लीज टेल मी इफ देयर एनी क्वेश्चन
फ्रॉम योर साइड आपकी तरफ से ऐसा कोई सवाल
प्रीवियस क्लास से रिलेटेड जो आप मुझसे
पूछना चाहते हैं तो आई एम रेडी टू गिव यू
आंसर।
कोई सवाल आप मुझसे पूछना चाहते हैं?
कोई सवाल है तो प्लीज बताइए।
तब तक के लिए थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं। दो
मिनट दो मिनट के लिए वेट करते हैं ताकि
बाकी जो स्टूडेंट्स हैं वह भी लाइव क्लास
में ज्वाइन हो जाए। वह भी लाइव क्लास को
ज्वाइन कर लें। तो तो
बोलिए मोहम्मद ओके हेलो मोहम्मद 8197
हेलो हेलो हेलो एवरीवन
मुझे एक सच में एक चीज बताओ सबको मेरी
क्लासेस समझ में आ रही है?
ओके अपडेट्स ऑफ नोट्स इन योर डेफोनिक्स
एप्लीकेशन
सून जल्दी सही बोल रहे हो कि उधर इज द
बेस्ट प्लेस टू प्रोवाइड द नोट्स
मैं उसको अगले आने वाले दो-ती दिन में
अपडेट करवा दूंगा। ओके।
ओके और किसी का कोई सवाल सर डस मैप पब्लिक
आईपी एड्रेस कम्स अंडर एक्सटर्नल पेन
टेस्ट देखिए एक्सटर्नल पेन टेस्टिंग
ये आपका हो सकता है आपका पब्लिक जो आईपी
एड्रेस है वो एक्सटर्नल पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग में आ सकता है बट उसके लिए भी
आपको क्या करना है हर चीज के लिए आपके पास
अथॉरिटी होनी चाहिए। विदाउट अथॉरिटी प्लीज
डू नॉट ट्राई एनी ट्रिक्स या टैिक्स बिकॉज़
हो सकता है कि आप इतने कैपेबल नहीं हो और
उसकी वजह से आप किसी ट्रैप में या किसी इल
इललीगल एक्टिविटी का शिकार हो जाओ जिसकी
वजह से आपको अपनी लाइफ में बहुत सारी
परेशानी और सामना कर करना पड़ जाए जो आपने
कभी सोची नहीं होंगी।
तो ओके चलिए फिर क्लास को स्टार्ट करते
हैं। तो मुझे लगता है इतने स्टूडेंट्स आते
हैं। इससे ज्यादा स्टूडेंट्स नहीं आते। तो
मेरी आप लोगों से एक रिक्वेस्ट है। प्लीज
अगर आपको सच में ऐसा लगता है कि सर जो आप
पढ़ा रहे हो जो क्लासेस चल रही हैं वो
आपको कोई वैल्यू प्रोवाइड कर सकती हैं या
कोई वैल्यू प्रोवाइड कर रही हैं या आपको
लगता है कि फ्यूचर में यह काफी वैल्यूुएबल
इंफॉर्मेशन है आपके लिए क्योंकि मेरी तरफ
से तो यह वह इंफॉर्मेशन है जो पेड
सर्टिफिकेशंस में या पेड क्लासेस में
पढ़ाई जाती है। मेरी तरफ से वह इंफॉर्मेशन
मैं आपको यहां पर फ्री में पढ़ा रहा हूं।
बट आपको ऐसा लगता है कि नहीं सर आप सही
बोल रहे हो और आपकी जो इंफॉर्मेशन है सच
में बहुत ही ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। काफी
वैल्यूुएबल इंफॉर्मेशन है हमारी लाइफ में
या हमारे करियर में काफी वैल्यू ऐड करने
वाली है। तो अगर आप लोगों को ऐसा लगता है
तो प्लीज मेरी रिक्वेस्ट यह है कि आप इसको
ज्यादा से ज्यादा लोगों के साथ शेयर कीजिए
और प्लीज उनको भी बोलिए कि अगर और खासकर
उनके साथ शेयर कीजिए जो सच में यह चीजें
सीखना चाहते हैं। जो सच में
अपने जो पेड कोर्सेज से पैसा बचाना चाहते
हैं उसको कहीं सही जगह यूटिलाइज करना
चाहते हैं तो प्लीज उनके साथ शेयर कीजिए
और उनको भी बोलिए अगर उनको भी अगर यह
चीजें पसंद आ रही है तो प्लीज शेयर सो दैट
कि हम इसको इतना बड़ा बनाएं कि
शायद लोगों को इस चीज के लिए पैसे ना देना
पड़े क्योंकि बहुत सारी चीजें हैं जो हर
चीज के लिए आप आपसे पैसे मांगते हैं सब इस
चीज़ के लिए जो चीज़ हम यहां पर पढ़ा रहे
हैं। यही सेम चीज़ उनके कोर्सेज में बैचज़
में होती है और वही चीज़ यहां पर है।
ज्यादा कुछ अंतर नहीं है क्योंकि हो कुछ
प्रैक्टिकल जो मैं अवॉइड कर रहा हूं चिंता
मत कीजिए। उसका भी मैं अल्टरनेट कोई
सॉल्यूशन निकालूंगा या कोई पेड वर्कशॉप या
पेड वेबिनार जिसमें मैं जो प्रैक्टिकल
यहां पर शो नहीं कर सकता उसके लिए एक
सेटअप करूं आपके लिए वो आपको प्रैक्टिकल
दिखाऊं। खास कर सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का एक
प्रैक्टिकल्स मैं सोच रहा हूं कि आपके लिए
बनाऊं और उसके लिए एक पेड वेबिनार ले आऊं
ताकि यहां की जो YouTube की जो पॉलिसी का
वायलेशन भी ना हो और आप लोगों को एक ट्रुथ
एक रियल नॉलेज गेन करने को मिले। तो उसके
लिए भी सोचते हैं हम डोंट वरी। तो प्लीज
अगर ऐसा लगता है प्लीज शेयर इट। दूसरों को
दूसरों को बोलिए आइए और ज्वाइन करें। ओके?
तो चलिए क्लास को स्टार्ट करते हैं। क्लास
को स्टार्ट करें। फिर
आर यू रेडी? सब लोग रेडी हैं क्लास
स्टार्ट करने के लिए?
ओके। एक चीज मैं आपको बता देता हूं कि हो
सकता है अभी मैं प्रैक्टिकल नहीं करवा रहा
या किसी चीज का प्रैक्टिकल मैं अवॉइड कर
रहा हूं। तो यह मत सोचना कि उसके
प्रैक्टिकल्स नहीं होंगे। उसके
प्रैक्टिकल्स होंगे। क्योंकि
मैं आपका जो थ्योरी के बेस पर आपका जो बेस
है उसको स्ट्रांग करना चाहता हूं। आपके
फंडामेंटल्स को स्ट्रांग करना चाहता हूं
या जो भी कांसेप्ट है जो भी कंटेंट है या
जो भी आप बोल सकते हो कि जो आपका
फाउंडेशनल नॉलेज है वो स्ट्रांग करना
चाहता हूं ताकि जब चीजें आपके सामने आए आप
उस चीज को सुनकर आपको ऐसा ना लगे वो पहली
बार है या आपको ऐसा ना लगे कि मेरे लिए
कुछ नई चीज है। आप उस सुनने से कुछ सोच
समझ पाओ कि ओके इसका मतलब यह हो सकता है
और मेरे यह अप्रोच हो सकती है। चलिए फिर
स्टार्ट करते हैं हमारे सेशन पर। तो
आज की जो क्लास स्टार्ट हो रही है वह
क्लाइंट साइड इनेशन गैदरिंग एंड रिकॉन से
स्टार्ट होने वाली है और मोस्टली यह
थ्योरेटिकली ये प्रैक्टिकल जिसमें भी नहीं
है, मैं आपको पहले बता देता हूं कि मुझे
पता है कि स्टूडेंट स्टूडेंट्स यह ना सोच
के आए हो कि सर प्रैक्टिकल देखने को
मिलेगा क्योंकि जो चीजें यहां पर डिस्कस
हो रही है, वह चीजें आपकी प्रैक्टिकल शो
करने के लिए मुझे पूरा एक
टाइम फ्रेम चाहिए। टाइम फ्रेम तो नहीं
चाहिए। बेसिकली आपके लिए एक ऐसी जगह प्लान
करूंगा जहां पर वह प्रैक्टिकली मैं आपको
शो कर पाऊं। क्योंकि आपको पता है सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग है इसमें सबसे ज्यादा। तो
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के लिए आपको एक
प्रैक्टिकल सेटअप करना भी एक चैलेंज है।
तो वो चैलेंज को हम एक्सेप्ट कर रहे हैं
और डेफिनेटली आपको मैं वो उसका जो बेसिक
रिक्वायरमेंट है फेसिंग कैंपेन कैसे
डिजाइन करते हैं? प्री टेक्स्टिंग कैसे
करते हैं? वीबीएम एक्रो डेवलपमेंट कैसे
करते हैं? ये सारी चीजें तो हम यहां
प्रैक्टिकली सीख लेंगे। बट वो एक्चुअल में
एग्जीक्यूट कैसे करना है और कैसे
प्रैक्टिकली वो होता है वो चीज के लिए मैं
आपके लिए प्लान कर रहा हूं अभी के लिए। तो
चलिए तो लास्ट की जो क्लास थी उसमें हमने
क्या सीखा? हमने दो चीजें क्लियर की लास्ट
की क्लास में। सबसे पहली चीज की
फंडामेंटल्स ऑफ क्लाइंट्स एंड अटैक्स।
दूसरी चीज हमने सीखी
वेरियस टाइप्स ऑफ अटैक वेक्टर्स। मतलब कि
हम कितने टाइप्स के अटैक वेक्टर्स यूज़ कर
सकते हैं क्लाइंट साइड अटैक परफॉर्म करने
के लिए? वह कौन-कौन से अटैक वेक्टर्स हैं
जो हम यूज़ कर सकते हैं क्लाइंट साइड अटैक
परफॉर्म करने के लिए। आई होप कि ये चीज आप
सबको क्लियर है। यह सबको पता है। नाउ इट्स
टाइम टू स्टेप इनू द एक्चुअल एग्जीक्यूशन
फज़। और अब हम अपना सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट और
सबसे क्रिटिकल फज़ स्टार्ट करने जा रहे
हैं। दैट इज कॉल्ड क्लाइंट साइड
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग एंड रिकॉल। ओके। तो
चलिए स्टार्ट करते हैं। क्लाइंट साइड
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग।
व्हेन परफॉर्मिंग ए क्लाइंट साइड अटैक द
सक्सेस ऑफ द अटैक विल कम डाउन टू द
एक्यूरेसी ऑफ द इंफॉर्मेशन यू गैदर अबाउट
योर टारगेट्स या टारगेट और द क्लाइंट साइड
सॉफ्टवेयर और कॉन्फ़िगरेशन रनिंग ऑन द
टारगेट सिस्टम्स। मतलब यह है कि एक बात आप
बिल्कुल अपने दिमाग में बैठा लीजिए कि
आपके अटैक की सक्सेस इस बात पर डिपेंड
करती है कि आपने अपने टारगेट और उसके
सिस्टम कॉन्फ़िगरेशन के बारे में कितनी
एक्यूरेट इंफॉर्मेशन और थरो इंफॉर्मेशन
निकाली है। समझ में नहीं आया होगा। मैं
रिपीट कर रहा हूं कि आपका जो अटैक है उसकी
सक्सेस रेट इस बात पे डिपेंड करती है कि
आपने जो इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट की है आपके
टारगेट के बारे में और उसकी जो सिस्टम
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन उसके बारे में वो कितनी
एक्यूरेट है और वो कितनी एक्चुअल या वैलिड
इंफॉर्मेशन है इस बात पे आपके अटैक की
सक्सेस बहुत ज्यादा डिपेंड करती है।
क्योंकि अगर आपकी इंफॉर्मेशन क्योंकि अगर
आपकी इंफॉर्मेशन अगर सॉलिड इंफॉर्मेशन है
तो आपका जो एक्सप्लइटेशन अटेमप्ट होगा जो
आपका एक्सप्लइटेशन फेज होगा वो 100%
सक्सेस होगा सक्सेसफुल होगा। अदरवाइज अगर
आपकी जो इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग स्किल है वो
वीक है। आपको इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करनी
नहीं आती खासकर के क्लाइंट साइड
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग में या क्लाइंट साइड
अटैक्स के अंदर तो फिर यह भी गारंटी है कि
आपका जो एक्सप्लइटेशन अटेम्प्ट होगा वो भी
100% फेल होगा। उसके सक्सेस रेट बिल्कुल
0% होंगे। इट इज सिंपल एज सिंपल एज डेट।
ओके? आई होप आई एम क्लियर। यह चीज आपको
क्लियर हो गई होगी कि अगर आपको आपके
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक को सक्सेस बनाना है,
उसको सक्सेस करना है तो आपके पास आपके
क्लाइंट की आपके एंप्लॉय की जो इंफॉर्मेशन
है वो एक्यूरेट इंफॉर्मेशन होनी चाहिए।
आपके पास वो इंफॉर्मेशन बिल्कुल 100%
सॉलिड इंफॉर्मेशन होनी चाहिए। सो इन ऑर्डर
फॉर यू टू सक्सेसफुली एक्सप्लइट ए क्लाइंट
साइड वनेबिलिटी और मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन यू
मस्ट फर्स्ट नो व्हाट क्लाइंट साइड
सॉफ्टवेयर इज रनिंग ऑन द टारगेट सिस्टम।
बस इसका मतलब भी वही है कि आपको यह पता
होना चाहिए कि आपके टारगेट सिस्टम पर कौन
से क्लाइंट सॉफ्टवेयर इंस्टॉल्ड हैं या
रनिंग है। और इस चीज के लिए हम क्या करते
हैं? क्लाइंट साइड इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग एंड
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग का ही यूज करते हैं।
नेक्स्ट
अभी एक चैलेंज होता है। इस एक चैलेंज लेते
हैं। ठीक है? कि फॉर एग्जांपल इमेजिन
कीजिए कि आपने अपने टारगेट के बारे में जो
आपका जो टारगेट है, आपने उसके बारे में
इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट की। आपने अपने टारगेट
को आइडेंटिफाई किया और आपके पास क्या है?
उस टारगेट की एक ईमेल आईडी है। उस टारगेट
की आपके पास एक ईमेल आईडी है। यह आपका
टारगेट है। यह कंपनी है। यह कंपनी में यह
आपका टारगेट है। यह फॉर एग्जांपल ये आपका
एचओ एचआर डिपार्टमेंट है या फाइनेंस
डिपार्टमेंट है। ये आपका टारगेट है। तो
इसकी आपके पास एक ईमेल आईडी है एम्प्लॉय@
accg्रुप.com
लेकिन आपको यह नहीं पता कि वो अपने
कंप्यूटर पर कौन सा ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम रन कर
रहे हैं। अब ये जो एचआर डिपार्टमेंट है
अपने कंप्यूटर पर कौन सा ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
यूज़ कर रहे हैं। ये इंफॉर्मेशन आपके पास
नहीं है। Windows यूज़ कर रहे हैं, Linux
यूज़ कर रहे हैं या Mac OS यूज़ कर रहे हैं।
और ना ही आपको यह पता कि उनके ब्राउज़र
उनके ब्राउज़र के बारे में कि कौन सा
ब्राउज़र वो यूज़ कर रहे हैं। Mac OS यूज़ कर
रहे हैं, Chrome यूज़ कर रहे हैं, Firefox
यूज़ कर रहे हैं या Browser यूज़ कर रहे
हैं, Tor यूज़ कर रहे हैं। कौन सा ब्राउज़र
वो यूज़ कर रहे हैं। यह इंफॉर्मेशन भी आपके
पास नहीं है। और साथ ही साथ आपको यह भी
नहीं पता कि Microsoft Office इंस्टॉल भी
है या नहीं है। Microsoft Office को यह
यूज़ भी करते हैं या नहीं करते हैं। आपके
पास बस इतनी इंफॉर्मेशन है कि यह आपकी
टारगेट टारगेट सिलेक्शन है और टारगेट
सिलेक्शन की ईमेल एड्रेस है। इसके अलावा
आपके पास कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है। और
स्क्रीन पर जो भी मैंने कंटेंट लिखा है,
यह आपके लिए बिल्कुल इजी है। जैसे कि आप
हिंदी में पढ़ रहे हो, जैसे मैं पढ़ा रहा
हूं, वही सारी चीजें यहां पर लिखी हुई है।
सो दैट कि आप इजी कंपेयर कर पाओ। तो
नेक्स्ट अब इतनी सारी इंफॉर्मेशन मिसिंग
है। इसके बावजूद भी अगर आप डायरेक्टली कोई
एक ऐसा मिलेशियस डॉक्यूमेंट बनाते हो और
टारगेट के पास भेज देते हो उसको
एग्जीक्यूशन के लिए तो उस केस में आप क्या
कर रहे हो? यू आर एसेंशियली शूट शूटिंग इन
द डार्क डार्क मतलब कि आप अंधेरे में तीर
चला रहे हो। भैया कि आपके पास इंफॉर्मेशन
नहीं है। लेकिन आप क्या कर रहे हो? अंधेरे
में तीर चला रहे हो। अंधेरे में एक पेलोड
एग्जीक्यूट कर रहे हो। बिल्कुल ब्लाइंडली
कि देखते हैं सक्सेस होगा या नहीं होगा।
तो किसी भी प्रोफेशनल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
में, किसी भी रेड टीम इंगेजमेंट में या
किसी भी ऑफेंसिव सिक्योरिटी टेस्टिंग में
कभी भी अंधेरे में तीर नहीं चलाए जाते।
इसी के लिए क्या करते हैं हम? इसी अंधेरे
को दूर करने के लिए हम किसका यूज़ करते
हैं? क्लाइंट साइड इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग।
इसी चीज को हम क्या करते हैं? क्लाइंट
साइड इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग की हेल्प से जो
अंधेरे अंधेरे में जो तीर चला रहे थे
अंधेरे में हम क्या करें? ब्लाइंडली अपने
जो पेलोड है उसको एग्जीक्यूट करके देख रहे
हैं। इस चीज को किस चीज से दूर किया जा
सकता है? क्लाइंट साइड इनेशन गैदरिंग और
ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग इन्हीं की हेल्प
से इसको क्या किया जा सकता है? अवॉइड किया
जा सकता है। तो नाउ कम्स टू आवर जस्ट लाइक
एनी ट्रेडिशनल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्ट।
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन गैदरिंग कैन बी ब्रेकन डाउन
इनू टू कैटेगरीज डिपेंडिंग ऑन द नेचर ऑफ
इंटरेक्शन विद द टारगेट। जैसे कि किसी भी
ट्रेडिशनल पेट्रेशन
नेटवर्क पेट्रेशन टेस्टिंग में होता है।
यहां भी इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग को हम दो
तरीके से कर सकते हैं या दो कैटेगरी में
डिवाइड करते हैं। सबसे पहली कैटेगरी कौन
सी आती है? नॉर्मल जब हम पेन टेस्टिंग की
बात करते हैं, वहां पर हम बोलते हैं पैसिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग। लेकिन क्लाइंट साइड
में हम क्या बोलते हैं? पैसिव क्लाइंट
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग। पैसिव क्लाइंट
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग इनवॉल्व्स कलेक्टिंग
डाटा अबाउट टारगेट यूज़र्स सिस्टम्स एंड
नेटवर्क विदाउट डायरेक्टली इंटैक्टिंग विद
नेम दिस अप्रोच एम्स टू गैदर इंफॉर्मेशन
पैसिवली फ्रॉम द
पब्लिकली अवेलेबल सोर्स थ्रू टेक्निक लाइक
ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस। मतलब यहां भी हम
क्या करते हैं? यहां भी हमारा गोल होता है
कि टारगेट के बारे में बिना टारगेट के साथ
डायरेक्टली इंटैक्ट किए इंफॉर्मेशन या
डाटा कलेक्ट करना। और यह सब हम कैसे करते
हैं? पब्लिकली अवेलेबल सोर्स की हेल्प से
जिसे साइबर सिक्योरिटी में हम बोलते हैं
ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस ओसेंट बोलते हैं। और
अगर किसी को ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस की
टेक्निक नहीं पता है तो मैं कि क्लाइंट की
प्रोफाइलिंग कैसे की जाती है? विद दी
हेल्प ऑफ ए Twitter विद दी हेल्प ऑफ एंडin
या विद दी हेल्प ऑफ ए Instagram वह चीज हम
क्या करने वाले हैं? मैं आपको एक क्विक
रिवीजन करवा दूंगा क्योंकि ऑलरेडी ओपन
सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस जो सीरीज है उसमें मैंने
वो चीजें कवर की हैं। बट आपके क्विक
रिवीजन के लिए ताकि आपको रिफ्रेश हो जाए।
आपको वो चीज दोबारा से ना देखनी पड़े या
वहां पर ना जाना पड़े। इसके लिए मैं यहां
पर कुछ क्लासेस इसकी भी इंक्लूड कर लूंगा
कि Lindin से या Instagram से या Twitter
से आप प्रोफाइलिंग कैसे क्रिएट कर सकते
हो। किसी भी टारगेट एंप्लई के बारे में
प्रोफाइलिंग बनाना मतलब टारगेट सिलेक्शन
करना। कौन कैसे कर सकते हैं मैनुअली हम वो
चीजें मैं आपको सिखा दूंगा। ओके तो
नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट बात करते हैं। अभी हम ये
चीज पता चल गई। तो अभी हम बात करते हैं
पैसिव क्लाइंट इंफॉर्मेशनेशन गैदरिंग
टूल्स एंड टेक्निक्स। टूल्स और टेक्निक्स
की हम बात करते हैं। तो सबसे पहले
टेक्निक्स क्या आती है इसमें? ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस। क्या आती है आपकी? ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस। फॉर एग्जांपल्स सर्चिंग सोशल
मीडिया प्लेटफार्म लाइक Lindin, Twitter
फॉर एंप्लॉय प्रोफाइल, कंपनी
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन और जॉब पोस्टिंग। तो सबसे
पहले हम क्या करते हैं? किसके अंदर? ओपन
सोशल इंटेलिजेंस के अंदर सोशल मीडिया
रिकॉर्ड करते हैं। इसमें हम क्या करते
हैं? कंपनी की Lindin प्रोफाइल को के बारे
में इंफॉर्मेशन निकालते हैं। Lindin
प्रोफाइल को विजिट करते हैं। Twitter
हैंडल को विजिट करते हैं। कंपनी की जो जॉब
पोस्टिंग्स है उसके बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन
स्कैन करते हैं। अब जॉब पोस्टिंग के बारे
में क्यों इंफॉर्मेशन स्कैन करते हैं?
क्योंकि जॉब पोस्टिंग में अक्सर हमें एक
आईडिया मिल जाता है या कई बार वो
इंफॉर्मेशन मिल जाती है कि कंपनी कौन से
टेक्निकल स्टक यूज कर रही है। कैसे? फॉर
एग्जांपल कंपनी ने एक एक पोस्ट निकाली है।
हो सकता है कि वह चाहे 6 महीने पहले
निकाली हो लेकिन वो Lindin पर पड़ी हुई
है। लुकिंग फॉर Windows एडमिन विद
Microsoft Office 365 एक्सपीरियंस। मतलब
कि एक चीज आपको कंफर्म होगी कि जो कंपनी
है वो Windows सर्वर प्लस में MS Office
365 यूज़ करें। मतलब आपको दो इनेशन यहां से
हिंट मिल गई। साथ के साथ ओपन सोर्स
सेंटेंस में हम क्या करते हैं? ब्राउजिंग
पब्लिक फॉर्म्स और वेबसाइट्स फॉर डिस्कशन
अबाउट द ऑर्गेनाइजेशन और इट्स टेक्नोलॉजी।
हम क्या करते हैं कि जो भी पब्लिकली
अवेलेबल फॉर्म्स होते हैं हो सकता है कि
कंपनी खुद का कोई फॉर्म्स चला रही हो कि
जहां पर अपने बिजनेस रिलेटेड न्यूज़ वहां
पर पब्लिश करती हो। जहां पर एंप्लाइज अपने
आईडियाज शेयर करते हो या कहीं ऐसी जगह पर
वो चीजें शेयर करती हैं जहां पर वो जैसे
अपने आपको कुछ भी अपडेट कर रही हैं या कुछ
भी फ्यूचर में क्या करने का कोई प्लान है
वो सारी चीजें शेयर करते हैं या वेबसाइट
पर कुछ डिस्कशंस हैं मतलब ऑर्गेनाइजेशन से
रिलेटेड या उसकी टेक्नोलॉजी से रिलेटेड
आपको कहीं पर भी कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन मिल
रही है वो भी हम क्या करते हैं फिल्टर आउट
करने की कोशिश करते हैं फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश करते हैं विद दी हेल्प ऑफ ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस इसमें ज्यादातर हम टूल्स कौन
से यूज़ करते हैं। जैसे कि Google Dork
किंग एडवांस सर्च क्वरीज का हम यूज़ करते
हैं। Maltigगo अब Maltigगo फ्री तो है
नहीं। फ्री में इतनी ज्यादा इनेशन देखने
को मिलती नहीं। लेकिन Maltigगo आपको
ज्यादातर किसके अंदर देखने को मिल जाता
है? जहां पर जो प्रोफेशनल पेंट टेस्टिंग
होती है कंपनीज़ के अंदर वो आपको पेड वर्जन
देते हैं। या फिर आप क्या कर सकते हो?
हार्वेस्टर का यूज़ कर सकते हो। जो ईमेल
हार्वेस्टिंग जिसके हेल्प से हम कर सकते
हैं। उसमें काफी आपको वैलुएबल इंफॉर्मेशन
मिल जाती है। नेक्स्ट आपका आता है सेकंड
टेक्निक। कौन सी होती है? सर्च इंजन
रिकॉर्ड फॉर एग्जांपल यूजिंग एडवांस सर्च
क्वरीज मतलब सिंपल है। इसमें हम क्या कर
सकते हैं? Google सर्च इंजन का यूज़ करते
हैं। उसमें हम एडवांस सर्च क्वरीज का यूज़
करते हैं इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट करने के लिए।
जैसे शेड हो गया, Google D हो गए, डग डक
गो हो गया। मतलब हम उसमें फिल्टर लगाते
हैं और फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करते हैं
कि कौन-कौन सी चीजें आपके लिए वैल्यूुएबल
इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड कर रही हैं। तो दैट
इज कॉल्ड योर पैसिव क्लाइंट इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग। इसमें काफी आपको वैलुएबल
इंफॉर्मेशन मिल जाती है। नेक्स्ट आता है
आपका एक्टिव क्लाइंट इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग।
अभी यहां पर गेम बदल जाता है पूरी पेन
टेस्टिंग का। एक्टिव क्लाइंट इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग इनवॉल्व्स इंटरेक्टिंग डायरेक्टली
विद टारगेट सिस्टम्स, एप्लीकेशनेशंस और
यूज़र्स टू गैदर डाटा अबाउट देयर क्लाइंट
साइड कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस, वनेबिलिटीज और
बिहेवियर। यहां पर क्या होता है कि जो आप
एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशनेशन गैदरिंग में यहां पर
क्या करते हो आप? आप जो टारगेट सिस्टम्स
है उनकी जो एप्लीकेशनेशंस है या जो जो
यूज़र्स है उसके साथ डायरेक्ट इंटैक्ट करते
हैं। एक्टिव क्लाइंट इनेशन गैदरिंग में आप
क्या कर सकते हो? क्या करते हो? कर सकते
हो नहीं करते हो डायरेक्ट क्लाइंट के साथ
या यूजर के साथ इंटैक्ट करते हो। और एक
चीज ध्यान रखना मैं इसको बिल्कुल ध्यान से
सुनना या कहीं पर राइट डाउन कर लेना या
बिल्कुल आप दिमाग में बैठा लेना या इसको
बिल्कुल नोट समझो। इंपॉर्टेंट नोट समझो।
जब भी हम क्लाइंट साइड जब भी हम क्या करते
हैं कि हम क्लाइंट साइड टेस्टिंग करते हैं
और क्लाइंट टेस्ट टेस्टिंग में जब हम बात
करते हैं एक्टिव इंटरेक्शन की तो यहां पर
एक्टिव इंटरेक्शन का मतलब यह नहीं है कि
हम पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करते हैं। नहीं यहां पर
जो हम बाकी पेन टेस्टिंग में क्या करते
हैं कि पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करते हैं,
एनुमिलेशन करते हैं। वो सारी चीजें करते
हैं। बट इसमें ऐसा नहीं है। पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग करते हैं। नहीं इसका मतलब है कि
हम एंप्लॉय एंप्लॉय को ही अपने टच पॉइंट
के रूप में यूज़ करते हैं। मतलब जो
एंप्लॉय है उसके साथ हम कम्युनिकेशन करते
हैं। उसके साथ कोई रिलेशनशिप इस्टैब्लिश
करते हैं या कुछ डेली बिजनेस ऑपरेशंस है
उसी के बेस पे कुछ ऐसी स्टोरी कुछ ऐसी
चीजें तैयार करते हैं ताकि हम डायरेक्टली
कंपनी के एंप्लई के साथ इंटरेक्ट करते हैं
और उन्हीं को अपना क्या करते हैं? अपना टच
पॉइंट बनाते हैं और उनको क्या करते हैं हम
या तो कोई कस्टम लिंक भेजते हैं या कोई
प्री टेक्स्ट करके कोई ईमेल भेजते हैं या
उनके साथ ऐसा कम्युनिकेशन इस्टैब्लिश करते
हैं ताकि वहां से हमें कोई वैल्यूएबल कोई
इंपॉर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन मिल जाए या हम कुछ
ऐसा करवा लें उनसे कि वहां से हम डाटा पुल
कर पाएं। वहां से हम क्या कर पाएं? उनकी
हेल्प से वो डाटा पुल कर पाएं। तो नाउ
कम्स टू आवर एक्टिव क्लाइंट इनेशन गैदरिंग
टूल्स एंड टेक्निक्स की। तो सबसे पहले
इसमें हम क्या करते हैं? क्लाइंट
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग या हम जिसको बोल सकते हैं
दूसरा होता है ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग।
क्लाइंट फिंगरप्रिंटिंग इज अ टेक्निक यूज
टू गैदर इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट यूजर्स वेब
ब्राउज़र एंड सॉफ्टवेयर स्टक इन ऑर्डर टू
ऐड इन द डेवलपमेंट ऑफ क्लाइंट स्पेसिफिक
पेलोड फॉर इनिशियल एक्सेस। अब जो क्लाइंट
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग होती है उसमें हम क्या
करते हैं? हम इसमें यूजर्स का जो वेब
ब्राउज़र्स है और उसके अंदर जो भी
सॉफ्टवेयर इंस्टॉल्ड हैं या जो सिस्टम्स
हैं या उसके अंदर जो भी हम बोल सकते हैं
प्लगिंस हैं उनकी एग्जैक्ट इंफॉर्मेशन
निकालने की कोशिश करते हैं ताकि जो
क्लाइंट स्पेसिफिक पेलोड्स हैं उनको बनाया
जा सके। जो क्लाइंट स्पेसिफिक पेलोड है
उनको क्या किया जा सके? डिजाइन किया जा
सके। बनाया जा सके। इससे क्या होगा? और
इसमें हमारा जो हमारा मेन गोल क्या होता
है? हमारा मेन गोल होता है ब्राउज़र एंड
ब्राउज़र वर्जन इंफॉर्मेशन निकालना।
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम एंड ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
आर्किटेक्चर के बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन
कलेक्ट करना। ये हमारे प्राइमरी टारगेट
होते हैं कि हमें ये तीन इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए
कि भैया कौन सा ब्राउज़र यूज़ हो रहा है?
ब्राउज़र उसके बाद उसका कौन सा वर्जन है?
कौन सा ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम क्लाइंट ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम यूज़ कर रहा है? और उसकी
आर्किटेक्चर क्या है? 32 बिट है या 64 बिट
है? यह इंफॉर्मेशन तो हमें चाहिए ही चाहिए
क्लाइंट से। तो नेक्स्ट आपका आता है कौन
सा? सोशल इंजीनियरिंग टेक्निक हम क्या
करते हैं? सोशल इंजीनियरिंग टेक्निक का
यूज करते हैं। किसके लिए? रिकॉन के लिए।
रिकॉन के लिए। तो कैसे करते हैं? हम क्या
करते हैं? इंगेजिंग विद टारगेट
इंडिविजुअल्स और एंप्लाइज थ्रू फोन कॉल्स,
ईमेल्स या अदर कम्युनिकेशन चैनल्स टू गैदर
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन, क्रेडेंशियल्स और
एक्सेस परमिशंस। मतलब क्या है कि आप
एंप्लई से या तो किसी फोन कॉल्स के थ्रू
या उनकी जो कॉर्पोरेट चैट है उनकी जो चैट
है उसके जरिए आप क्या करते हो ऐसी बातें
कर बातें करते हो या ऐसी बातें करने की
कोशिश करते हो जिससे वो गलती से अपने
सॉफ्टवेयर वर्जन लीक कर दे बातोंबातों में
गलती से कोई ऐसी चीज या ऐसी बात या ऐसा
हिंट दे दे जिससे आपको पता चल जाए कि ओके
यह यह सॉफ्टवेयर यूज कर रहे हैं और
लेटेस्ट वर्जन है या ओल्ड वर्जन है। मतलब
आपको हिंट मिल जाए। फॉर एग्जांपल्स आप
क्या कर रहे हो? किसी एचआर डिपार्टमेंट से
बात कर रहे हो। तो हो सकता है आप ऐसे बोल
सकते हो कि सर हो सकता है कि आपके एचआर
पोर्टल में कुछ इशू आ रहा है। प्लीज टेल
मी कि आप AOब रीडर का कौन सा वर्जन यूज़ कर
रहे हो ताकि मैं आपको सही से वो फाइल शेयर
कर पाऊं। वो फाइल दे पाऊं। सो दैट कि आप
अपना काम कर पाए और मेरा भी आपका मेरा भी
टाइम वेस्ट ना हो। यह इस तरीके से आपको
अप्रोच बनानी पड़ेगी। इस तरह की अप्रोच
होती है। मैं एक एक एग्जांपल्स एक
सिनेरियो आपको आज एक डिस्कस करके दिखाऊंगा
कि एक कैसे सोशल के जरिए से आप यह सारी
चीजें कर सकते हो। नेक्स्ट
अभी बात करते हैं मेथोडोलॉजी वर्क फ्लो
मतलब नॉर्मली क्या कर सकते हो? नॉर्मली
नॉर्मली अब ये कोई फिक्स नहीं है कि यही
करना है। जस्ट नॉर्मली एक जो मैंने पढ़ाया
है उसको उसका एक ओवरव्यू है कि ओके सबसे
पहले आप क्या करते हो? पैसिव रिकॉर्ड में
ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस माइनिंग करते हो।
मतलब आपने Lindin का यूज़ किया, Google
Dorkin का यूज़ किया, टारगेट की लिस्ट
निकाली। वहां से टारगेट सिलेक्शन किया और
आपने क्या किया? थोड़ा बहुत अंदाजा लगाया
कि यह सॉफ्टवेयर वो यूज़ कर सकते हैं।
उसके बाद प्री टेक्स्ट कम्युनिकेशन करते
हो। आप एक्टिव फेस मतलब कि अभी नॉन
सस्िशियस वे में आप टारगेट के पास वो चीज
भेजने की कोशिश करते हो और कंफर्म करने की
कोशिश करते हो। क्या कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन आप
गैदर कर पा रहे हो या कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन
निकाल पा रहे हो? नहीं निकाल पा रहे हो।
थर्ड वन क्या है? फज़ आता है आपका ब्राउज़र
हुकिंग या बैनर गैबिंग जो आपके
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग फज़ आता है। इसमें क्या
करते हो आप जैसे ही आपने यूजर आपने क्या
किया प्री टेक्स्टिंग फज़ में कोई क्लिक
किया उसने उस चीज पे जो आपने भेजी है जो
भी चाहे उसके पीछे कोई भी कोड था कोई भी
स्क्रिप्ट थी कुछ भी था जो चाहे वो
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग पर्पस से ही क्यों ना हो
जैसे उस पे क्लिक करता है फिर क्या करते
हो आप उस कस्टम्स जो स्क्रिप्ट के जरिए
फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करते हो क्या
मुझे जो चीज़ चाहिए थी वह चीज़ मिली या नहीं
मिली। अब हो सकता है वह चीज आपको मिले
लेकिन वह गलत भी हो। 100% एक्यूरेसी की
गारंटी नहीं है। बट आपको उसको क्रॉस
वेरीफाई करना ही पड़ेगा। उसको क्रॉस
वेरीफाई आपको करना ही पड़ेगा।
तो यहां तक सबको क्लियर है? यहां तक सबको
सारी चीजें समझ में आ गई कि क्लाइंट्स एंड
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग होती क्या है?
मतलब आईडिया मिल गया कि व्हाट इज द
डिफरेंस बिटवीन नॉर्मल पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग और नॉर्मल एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग और पैसिव क्लाइंट इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग और एक्टिव क्लाइंट इन गैदरिंग में
क्या डिफरेंस है भैया? अगर जब हम एक्टिव
क्लाइंट इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग की बात करते
हैं और जब नॉर्मल हम एक्टिव इन गैदरिंग
करते हैं उसमें क्या डिफरेंस है?
एवरीवन क्लियर सबको यह चीज क्लियर है?
देखिए डीए की सीरीज में मैंने आपको
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग पढ़ाया था। वो
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग भी एक तरीका है
इंफॉर्मेशन निकालने का। बट मैंने क्या
बोला आपको कि वहां पर मैंने दो चीजें
पढ़ाई थी। वहां पे भी एक्टिव इनेशन
गैदरिंग पढ़ाई थी। पैसिव इनेशन गैदरिंग
पढ़ाई थी। तो अब पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
में तो कुछ नहीं बदला कि पैसिव इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग में तो ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस यूज
कर रहे हो वो वहां पर भी यूज कर रहे हो
यहां पर भी यूज कर रहे हो Google डोर किंग
वहां पे भी यूज़ कर रहे हो यहां पे यूज़ कर
रहे हो लेकिन जब एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
गैदरिंग की बात आती है तो एक्टिव इनेशन
गैदरिंग में वहां पे आप क्या करते हो आपने
क्या किया एक्टिवली उसके साथ टार के साथ
इंटैक्ट करते हो मतलब जो सर्वर था उसके
साथ उसके साथ सर्वर के आपने एंड मैप रन कर
लिया पोर्ट स्कैनिंग कर ली आपने उसके बाद
फर्दर उसमें एनुमरेशन कर लिया वो कर लिया
लेकिन यहां पर आप ऐसा कुछ भी नहीं कर रहे
हो। आप एक्टिवली किसके साथ इंटरेक्ट कर
रहे हो? क्लाइंट सेट अटैक्स में। आप
एक्टिवली इंटैक्ट कर रहे हो किसके साथ? उस
क्लाइंट के साथ उस एंप्लई के साथ जो
डायरेक्टली उस कंपनी के अंदर काम करता है।
वो कंपनी के अंदर जा रहा है। आपके लिए
वनेरेबल असेप्ट वही एसेट वही है। अभी आप
उस एंप्लई के ऊपर कौन सा पोर्ट स्कैन
चलाओगे? अभी तो आपको इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए कि
जो एंप्लई लैपटॉप यूज करता है या कंपनी के
अंदर जो डेस्कटॉप यूज करता है वह कौन सा
यूज करता है। कैसे वह ईमेल हैंडल करते
हैं। कैसे मैं उसको एक ईमेल भेज सकता हूं
और कन्वेंस कर पाऊं कि वो इस ईमेल पर
क्लिक करें या मैं कैसे उसको वह चीज
प्रोवाइड कर पाऊं जिससे मुझे बेनिफिट हो
और वह आपको सस्िशियस ना समझे। अंडरस्टुड?
बिल्कुल यहां पर कंपनी के साथ इंटरेक्ट कर
रहा है। आपके तरीके अलग हो सकते हैं। हो
सकता है कि सोशल इंजीनियरिंग की सारी
टेक्निक्स यूज़ कर सकते हो। यहां पर जो अभी
हम डिस्कस करने वाले हैं। नेक्स्ट क्लास
जो होगी आपकी क्लास नंबर 63 उसमें हम सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं। तो
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग क्या होती है? बिल्कुल
जीरो से स्टार्ट करूंगा। कितनी टेक्निक्स
होती हैं? क्या-क्या चीजें होती हैं? वो
सारी चीजें हम जीरो से डिस्कस करेंगे। वह
सारी टेक्निक्स अप्लाई कर सकते हो। आपको
एंड ऑफ द डे क्या चाहिए? जो आप पेलोड
डिजाइन करोगे वो पेलोड डिजाइन करने के लिए
आपके पास जो इंफॉर्मेशन मिलेगी वो
इंफॉर्मेशन एक्यूरेट होनी चाहिए। समझ गए?
वो इंफॉर्मेशन एक्यूरेट होनी चाहिए। बट
उसके लिए आपके पास ऑथराइजेशन होनी चाहिए।
जब आप किसी भी कंपनी का क्लाइंट साइड
अटैक्स टेस्टिंग करोगे या सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग पेन टेस्टिंग कर रहेगे। उस
टाइम पे आपके पास यह चीज अथॉरिटी होनी
चाहिए। कुछ भी इललीगल नहीं होना चाहिए और
जो अलाउड है जो आपके स्कोप में है वही
होना चाहिए कंटीन्यूसली आप उस के टच में
रहने चाहिए कि मैं यह करने जा रहा हूं यह
करने वाला हूं। ओके
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन व्हाट आई एम ट्राइंग टू
क्लियर यू कि मैं आपको क्या पढ़ाने की
कोशिश कर रहा हूं। चीजें बदल गई हैं।
अभी तक मैंने आपको जो कुछ पढ़ाया
वो पढ़ाया कि आपके पास इंटरनल नेटवर्क
एक्सेस मतलब आप उस नेटवर्क में हो या तो
आपका लैपटॉप है या आपके पास उस सर्वर का
एक्सेस मतलब कि आप उस सर्वर के साथ आपको
पेन टेस्टिंग के लिए उस नेटवर्क में कैसे
ना कैसे या तो वीपीए के थ्रू एक्सेस
प्रोवाइड किया हो या फिजिकली उस नेटवर्क
में हो या
एक मशीन आपको प्रोवाइड की है रिमोटली आप
उस नेटवर्क को पेन टेस्ट करने के लिए अभी
तक मैंने आपको यही पढ़ाया है इंटरनल
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग वो भी आधी पढ़ाई है
कंप्लीट नहीं पढ़ाई लेकिन अब जो मैं पढ़ा
रहा हूं यहां पर आपको पता ही नहीं
यहां पर आपको पता ही नहीं कि मैं इंटरनेट
इंटरनल नेटवर्क में घुस भी पाऊंगा नहीं
घुस पाऊंगा लेकिन वी आर ए पेंटेस्टर्स
हमारी जॉब है उस कंपनी को सिक्योरिटी
प्रोवाइड करनी उस चीज को हैकर से पहले वह
लूप लूप होल या वह रिस्क कंपनी को बताना।
दैट इज व्हाई हम एक्सटर्नल पेन टेस्टिंग
भी हमें सीखनी पड़ती है।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
अंडरस्टुड?
डोंट वरी। मैं आपके चैट देख रहा हूं। डोंट
वरी। अंडरस्टुड है। सबको समझ में आए?
स्टूडेंट तो कम है लेकिन जितने भी हैं
मेरे लिए काफी हैं। अगर दो स्टूडेंट्स भी
आ रहे हैं ना मैं उसको पढ़ाऊंगा। डोंट
वरी। आई विल नॉट स्टॉप। मैं पढ़ाऊंगा।
जबजब मुझे टाइम मिलेगा आपको मैं नॉलेज गेन
करवाऊंगा।
चलिए नेक्स्ट। चलो एक सिनेरियो लेते हैं
कि लेवरेजिंग सोशल इंजीनियरिंग फॉर एक्टिव
क्लाइंट इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग। चलो एक्टिव
क्लाइंट इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग मैंने आपको
पढ़ाया। चलिए फिर मैं बिल्कुल क्लियर कर
देता हूं कि एक्टिव क्लाइंट इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग का एक सिनेरियो लेते हैं। बिल्कुल
रियल वर्ल्ड जैसा सिनेरियो है कि कैसे
वो एक्टिव क्लाइंट इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
होगी। तो अभी तक मैंने आपको क्या पढ़ाया
कि एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग होती क्या
है? अब हम देखने वाले एक रियल वर्ल्ड
सिनेरियो जहां पर हम सीखेंगे कि कैसे एक
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स बिना किसी ऑटोमेटेड
स्कैनर के ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी का यूज करते
हुए और अपनी प्री टेक्स्टिंग स्किल का यूज
करके टारगेट की एग्जैक्ट सॉफ्टवेयर
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन निकाल सकता है। कैसे? एक
पेंटेस्टस
किसी भी इंसान के अगेंस्ट उसकी साइकोलॉजी
का यूज करके और अपनी प्री टेक्स्टिंग पावर
अपनी कम्युनिकेशन स्किल का यूज करके या
अपनी मैनपुलेशन स्किल का यूज करके
एग्जैक्ट सॉफ्टवेयर इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल सकता
है विद दी हेल्प ऑफ क्लाइंट इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग। तो यह एक कॉमन सिनेरियो हो सकता
है नॉर्मली आप देख सकते हो। लेकिन कभी
आपने सोचा नहीं होगा कि ऐसे भी हो सकता
है। नाउ लेट्स स्टार्ट।
एक्टिव क्लाइंट इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग।
एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग डज नॉट ऑलवेज
मींस रनिंग ऑटोमेटेड स्कैनर्स, सेंडिंग
नेटवर्क प्रोब्स एंड एनुमिटिंग एक्सपोज
सर्विज। अब एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग का
हमेशा यह मतलब नहीं है कि आप ऑटोमेटेड
स्कैनर्स को यूज़ करोगे, कोई नेटवर्क प्रोब
करोगे या कोई एक्सपोर्ट सर्विज का यूज
करोगे एनुमिशन के लिए। बिल्कुल नहीं।
हमेशा ऐसा नहीं होता। इन मेनी रियल वर्ल्ड
असेसमेंट स्पेशली ड्यूरिंग रेड टीम
ऑपरेशंस वैल्यूएबल इंटेलिजेंस कैन बी
कलेक्टेड थ्रू कंट्रोलोल्ड ह्यूमन
इंटरेक्शन प्रोफेशनल प्रेक्स्टिंग्स एंड
केयरफुल ऑब्जरवेशन कभी भी देखना आपको जो
एग्जैक्ट जो सॉलिड इंटेलिजेंस मिलती है जो
आप जिस पे आप 100% श्योर होते हो वो हमेशा
कहीं ना कहीं से आपको ह्यूमन इंटरेक्शन
मिलती है उस एंप्लई से बातचीत करके या उस
कंपनी के के डायरेक्ट इंटरेक्शन ह्यूमन
इंटरेक्शन से ज्यादा एक्यूरेट इनफेशन दी
है रेदर देन जो आप ऑटोमेटिक स्कैनर्स रन
करते हो या जो एक्सपोज सर्विस उससे
एक्यूरेट इनेशन किसके पास मिलेगी वहां पर
जो एंप्लॉय बैठा है वो वो आपकी रियल
असेसमेंट होती है। द दिस सिनेरियो
डेमोंस्ट्रेट हाउ ए पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स
कैन यूज़ सोशल इंजीनियरिंग प्रिंसिपल्स टू
गैदर इनेशन अबाउट ए टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस
सॉफ्टवेयर एनवायरमेंट विदाउट डायरेक्टली
अटैकिंग इट्स इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर। अभी मैं
आपको एक ऐसा डेमोंस्ट्रेशन शो करने वाला
हूं जिसमें एक पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग टेक्निक का यूज करेगा टारगेट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस के सॉफ्टवेयर एनवायरमेंट
को जानने के लिए बिना डायरेक्टली उसकी
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को अटैक किए। एंड द पर्पस
ऑफ़ दिस एग्जांपल इज नॉट टू इंक्रीज अन
ऑथराइज्ड एक्टिविटी। अब ये एग्जांपल मैं
आपको जो शो कर रहा हूं मेरा उसमें ऐसा कोई
भी पर्पस नहीं है कि आप यह सीखने के बाद
हर जगह अन ऑथराइज एक्टिविटी आप परफॉर्म
करें। बिल्कुल मैं इसके खिलाफ हूं। मैं
चाहता हूं मेरे जितने भी स्टूडेंट्स हैं
कोई भी इसको अन ऑथराइज वे में यूज ना
करें। इन ए प्रोफेशनल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्ट और
रेड टीम इंगेजमेंट। सच टेक्निक्स मस्ट
ओनली बी यूज्ड विद रिटन ऑथराइजेशन
क्लियरली डिफाइन स्कोप एंड प्रॉपर लीगल
अप्रूवल। जब आपके पास रिटन ऑथराइजेशन हो,
आपका स्कोप क्लियरली डिफाइन हो, साफ-साफ
उसमें लिखा हो कि आप कर सकते हो और आपके
पास लीगल अप्रूवल हो, देन ओनली आप यह
चीजें परफॉर्म करना। इस जैसे सिनेरियो को
परफॉर्म करना। अदरवाइज आपके पास अगर कुछ
भी रिडन में अथॉरिटी नहीं है, तो प्लीज डू
नॉट डू इट। डू नॉट परफॉर्म बिकॉज़ इसके जो
सरकमस्ट्ससेस होंगे
ना तो आप जानते ना मैं जानता कितने बड़े
एलगेशंस आपके ऊपर लगेंगे यू डोंट नो।
ओके तो नाउ लेट्स स्टार्ट।
चलो इन दिस सिनेरियो देयर आर टू मेन
एंटटीज। अब हमारे सिनेरियो में दो मेन
कररेक्टर्स हैं। जिसमें सबसे पहले जो
हमारा कररेक्टर है नितेश। नितेश इज ए
प्रोफेशनल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स एंड रेड
टीम ऑपरेटर्स हु हैज़ बीन ऑथराइज्ड टू
एक्सेस द सिक्योरिटी पोस्टर्स ऑफ द टारगेट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन। मतलब एक नितेश क्या है? एक
प्रोफेशनल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स है या एक
रेड टीम ऑपरेटर्स है जिसको ऑथराइज किया है
इस टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन ने उसके ऊपर
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्ट करने के लिए। मतलब उसको
एक लीगल अथॉरिटी दी गई है। उसको रिटर्न
अथॉरिटी दी गई है। उसके स्कोप में डिफाइन
किया कि भैया नितेश आप एक काम कर सकते हो।
आप एक टीम ऑपरेटर्स हो। आप एक सिक्योरिटी
टेस्टर्स हो। आपकी एक जिम्मेदारी है कि जो
मेरी ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस है उसके ऊपर आप सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग अटैक करके यह पता लगाओ कि
कितने एंप्लई मेरे ट्रेंड हैं। कितने
एंप्लॉय अनट्रेंड है ताकि हम उसको ट्रेन
करें और हमारे कंपनी कंपनी में सिक्योरिटी
अटैक होने मतलब साइबर अटैक होने से बचाएं।
दैट इज व्हाई यह आपका क्या है? एक एंटिटी।
दूसरा कैरेक्टर क्या है आपका? दूसरा एक
कैरेक्टर आपका है एसीजी कॉरपोरेशन
प्राइवेट लिमिटेड इज द टारगेट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन। यह वह टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
है जिस जिसके अंदर जो नितेश है वो एक पेन
टेस्टिंग परफॉर्म करने के लिए उसको ऑथराइज
किया गया है। इट हैज़ अ स्ट्रांग पेरीमीटर
डिफेंस वेल प्रोटेक्टेड पब्लिक फेसिंग
सर्वर्स एंड लिमिटेड एक्सटर्नली विज़िबल
वीकनेसेस। मतलब क्या है कि अब यह जो कंपनी
है अब इस जो हमारी टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है
इसका जो पेरीमीटर डिफेंस है वह बहुत
स्ट्रांग है। काफी प्रोटेक्ट किया गया है।
उसके पब्लिक फेसिंग सर्स को पूरी तरह से
प्रोटेक्ट किया गया है। उसके जो बाहर से
जो वीकनेसेस है बहुत कम है। नाउ बिकॉज़
एसीजी कॉरपोरेशंस एक्शन इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर
इज वेरी हार्ड। नितेश डिसाइड टू फोकस ऑन
क्लाइंट साइड इनेशन गैदरिंग। जब नितेश को
पता चला कि ओके जो आउटर पैरामीटर्स है जो
मेरे सर्वर्स हैं वह बहुत ज्यादा सिक्यर्स
हैं। चलिए फिर उसने अपना डिसीजन बदला।
उसने सोचा चलो कोई बात नहीं सिक्यर्स हैं
तो हम मुझे एक और टेक्निक आती है। कौन सी
आती है? सोशल इंजन टेक्निक। क्लाइंट साइड
इनेशन गैदरिंग या क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स। तो
मैं यहां पर क्या करूंगा? क्लाइंट साइड
अटैक्स परफॉर्म करूंगा। इंस्टेड ऑफ़
अटैकिंग द कंप्लीट सर्वर डायरेक्टली। ही
अटेम्प्ट टू लर्न मोर अबाउट द सॉफ्टवेयर
एनवायरमेंट यूज्ड बाय द एंप्लॉय। उसने
क्या सोच अभी क्या प्लान किया है कि ठीक
है मैं अब कंपनी के सर्वर्स को डायरेक्टली
नहीं टच करने वाला डायरेक्टली अटैक नहीं
करने वाला मैं क्या यूज करने वाला हूं
सबसे वनेरेबल चीज जो होती है किसी भी
कंपनी के लिए उनके एंप्लाइजज़ उन्हीं का
यूज़ करूंगा उन्हीं का यूज़ करके मैं क्या
करने वाला हूं सॉफ्टवेयर एनवायरमेंट के
बारे में पता लगाऊंगा। चलिए फिर द गोल इज़
टू आइडेंटिफाई यूज़फुल डिटेल्स सच ऐज़
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स ऑफिस सॉफ्टवेयर
डॉक्यूमेंट हैंडलिंग बिहेवियर एंड एंप्लई
रिस्पांस पैटर्न्स एंड दिस इनेशन कैन लेटर
हेल्प द सिक्योरिटी टीम अंडरस्टैंड हाउ
रियलिस्टिक क्लाइंट्स एंड रिस्क मे अपीयर
इन द ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस। चलिए फिर स्टेप वन
क्या अभी सिनेरियो हालांकि क्या है कि अभी
देखते हैं चलो अभी जो सिनेरियो है इस
सिनेरियो में आपको मैं एक चीज दिखाऊंगा कि
एक सिंपल टच पॉइंट की हेल्प से जो नितेश
जो हमने एक कैरेक्टर लिया है जो एक
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टस है वो एक सिंपल टच
पॉइंट की हेल्प से एक हाई वैल्यू वैल्यू
इंटेलिजेंस
में कैसे उसको कन्वर्ट करेगा। आई एम
रिपीटिंग अगेन कि नितेश कैसे सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग या क्लाइंट साइड टेक्निक्स का
यूज़ करके
कैसे एक सिंपल टच पॉइंट का यूज़ करते हुए
क्या करेगा? इंटेलिजेंस उस टच पॉइंट को
इंटेलिजेंस गैदरिंग में कन्वर्ट करेगा। और
इसके लिए वो क्या करेगा? टोटल सात स्टेप
परफॉर्म करेगा। जिनमें से चार फेज बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट है। सातवां क्या होता है? आपका
हर जगह रिपोर्टिंग होता है। तो इसलिए जो
सिक्स क्रिटिकल फज़ हैं जो वह यूज करने
वाला है और हमने क्या किया? हमने भी क्या
किया कि उनको छह फेजेस में कन्वर्ट किया
है। सबसे पहला रिसोर्स एंड प्रिपरेशन,
इनिशिएटिंग कांटेक्ट, रिस्पांस फ्रॉम द
कंपनी, एक्सप्लइटिंग द अपॉर्चुनिटी,
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग, एनालिसिस एंड रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट। यह जो छह पेज हैं जो हमने
ब्रेकडाउन किए हैं कि कौन से फेज पर नितेश
ने क्या किया और क्या उसको मिला वह सारी
चीजें हम वन बाय वन फेज बाय फेज डिस्कस
करने वाले हैं। उसके बाद रिपोर्टिंग सबको
पता है। जब यह चीजें मिल जाती हैं तो हम
रिपोर्टिंग करते हैं। नाउ कम्स टू आवर फेज
वन रिसर्च एंड प्रिपरेशन। रिसर्च एंड
प्रिपरेशन नितेश बिगिंस विद बेसिक रिकॉर्ड
ऑफ एसीजी कॉरपोरेशन पब्लिक वेबसाइट
ड्यूरिंग दिस फ ही नोटिस दैट द कंपनी हैज़
रिसेंटली पोस्टेड ए जॉब ओपनिंग द कैरियर
सेक्शन कंटेन एन ऑनलाइन रिज्यूम अपलोड
फीचर्स वेयर एपिकेंट्स कैन सबमिट देयर
सीवीज मतलब अब नितेश जो एक पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टर्स है जिसको एसीजी कॉरपोरेशन
प्राइवेट लिमिटेड कंपनी की पेन टेस्टिंग
करने की परमिशन दी गई है। जब वह एसीजी
कॉरपोरेशन की वेबसाइट को स्कैन करता है,
उसके ऊपर इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करता है, तब
उसे पता चलता है कि कंपनी में एक नई जॉब
के लिए ओपनिंग चल रही है। उन्होंने
रिसेंटली एक पोस्ट डाली है कि कंपनी में
वह हायरिंग कर रहे हैं किसी एक नई जॉब के
लिए और उसकी कम उस जो वेबसाइट है उस
वेबसाइट पर इसके लिए एक ऑनलाइन रिज्यूम
अपलोड फंक्शनैलिटी भी अवेलेबल है।
उन्होंने क्या है कि एक टैब एक मेनू ओपन
किया हुआ है जिसमें क्या कर सकता है जो
कैंडिडेट्स हैं वह अपनी सीवीज अब जो उनके
रिज्यूे हैं उनको क्या कर सकते हैं वो
सबमिट कर सकते हैं। नाउ एट दिस पॉइंट इट
इज वेरीेंट टू अंडरस्टैंड द इंटेंट। अब यह
वो समय है जहां पर आपको अपना इंटेंट या
यहां पर जो नितेश है उसका इंटेंट समझना
है। ठीक है? अब अब यह बताइए कि क्या करना
चाहिए?
क्या करना चाहिए? चलो मैं इसको अभी हटा
देता हूं।
क्या करना चाहिए?
अब यह चीज उसको स्टेप वन में पता चल गई कि
एक जॉब ओपनिंग पोर्टल है। ठीक है? जो वो
एक नया जॉब ओपनिंग पोर्टल वहां पर अपलोड
फंक्शनैलिटी अवेलेबल है। देन इन दैट केस
आप लोग क्या करोगे?
इस केस में आप लोग क्या करने वाले हैं?
मुझे ये बताओ साफ-साफ
आप लोगों के मन में क्या है? आप क्या
करोगे?
प्लीज जल्दी से बताइए। चाहे एक स्टूडेंट
है, चाहे दो स्टूडेंट है। तो आई वांट आंसर
फ्रॉम बोथ ऑफ यू।
अभी आपके दिमाग में क्या आता है? आप क्या
करोगे?
बताओ।
ओके
और कोई
और कोई चलो कांटेक्ट कैसे करोगे एचआर के
साथ
हाउ वुड यू कांटेक्ट विद एचआर और
कैसे करोगे
आप कैसे कांटेक्ट करोगे बताओ
इफ मींस रिज्यूुमे सेक्टेड
आई रिसीव्ड एन ईमेल फ्रॉम हिम एवरी
मॉर्निंग
नो नो नो सोचो दिमाग लगाओ हाउ वुड यू
एस्टैब्लिश ए कांटेक्ट विद एचआर
डिपार्टमेंट आपको एक अपॉर्चुनिटी मिली है।
आपको यह चीज मिली
आप रिज्यू में अपलोड कर सकते हो। यह
फंक्शन अवेलेबल है।
ओके।
तो मोहम्मद मुझे एक चीज बताओ। आप मालवेयर
एंबेड कर दोगे। डू यू नो वि सिस्टम दे आर
यूजिंग? कौन सा मालवेयर ऐड करोगे?
क्या आपको पता है कि कौन सा ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम वह यूज कर रहे हैं? क्या आपको यह
पता है
कौन सा सॉफ्टवेयर वो यूज कर रहे हैं? कहां
पर यह फाइल जा रही है? हाउ वुड यू नो? वो
ब्राउज़र यूज़ कर भी रहे हैं या नहीं कर
रहे? हाउ वुड यू नो?
कहां पर वो फाइल जा रही है? कौन इसको
हैंडल कर रहा है? कोई बोर्ड तो हैंडल नहीं
कर रहा हो या कोई फिजिकली कोई एंप्लई
हैंडल कर रहा है नहीं हैंडल कर रहा। हाउ
वुड यू नो यह चीज आपको पता है?
बताओ आप लोगों को यह चीज पता है?
बताओ बताओ।
देखो इंटरेक्ट नहीं करोगे जब तक मजा नहीं
आएगा। तो प्लीज इंटैक्ट विद मी।
जो कुछ मन में आता है बताओ। मैं हूं ना
आंसर देने के लिए। गलत लिख दोगे तो क्या
फर्क पड़ता है? चलो नहीं पता। बाकी
और कोई
दो ही स्टूडेंट्स हैं आंसर देने के लिए।
बाकी लोग बताइए क्या करोगे?
चलिए मैं बता देता हूं। हम अपना टाइम
वेस्ट नहीं करेंगे। चलो
नितेश इज नॉट ट्राइंग टू एक्सप्लोर द
अपलोड फंक्शनैलिटी। इज नॉट अटेमप्टिंग टू
बायपास फाइल रिस्ट्रिकशंस एग्जीक्यूट कोड
ऑन द सर्वर और अटैक द वेब एप्लीकेशन
इटसेल्फ।
अब जो नितेश है नितेश का गोल यहां पर फाइल
अपलोड वनेबिलिटीज को एक्सप्लइट करना
बिल्कुल भी नहीं है। वह क्या करेगा? वह इस
अपलोड पोर्टल को सिर्फ अपने इनिशिएशन ऑफ
कांटेक्ट के रूप में यह जो पहला टच पॉइंट
है, पहला टच पॉइंट बनाने बनाने के लिए यूज
करेगा। पहला टच पॉइंट बनाने के लिए यूज
करेगा।
ही सीज रिज्यूम अपलोड पोर्टल एज ए
लेजिटिमेट इंटरेक्शन पॉइंट बिटवीन एन
एक्सटर्नल यूजर एंड द कंपनी एचआर
डिपार्टमेंट। क्योंकि उसने देखा कि भाई जो
अपलोड पोर्टल है वह एक लेजिटमेट इंटरेक्शन
पॉइंट है। किसके बीच में? मेरे बीच में और
कंपनी एचआर डिपार्टमेंट के बीच में। तो
यहां पर अपलोड फंक्शनैलिटी को टेस्ट करने
का कोई फायदा नहीं। लेकिन यहां पर एक
लेजिटमेट, एक वैलिड, एक जेन्युइन पॉइंट
है। जहां पर एक एक्सटर्नल यूजर और एक
कंपनी एचआरमेंट जो एचआर डिपार्टमेंट है
कांटेक्ट इस्टैब्लिश कर रहे हैं। नाउ इन
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग एंड क्लाइंट साइड
टेस्टिंग सच इंटरेक्शन पॉइंट आर
एक्सट्रीमली वैल्यूुएबल। इस तरह के
इंटरेक्शन पॉइंट्स हैं। वह बहुत ज्यादा
वैल्यूुएबल होते हैं। बिकॉज़ दे प्रोवाइड ए
रियलिस्टिक कम्युनिकेशन चैनल दैट डज़ नॉट
लुक सस्िशियस। क्योंकि यह ऐसे चैनल्स हैं
जहां पर कभी भी आप सामने वाली पार्टी उसको
सस्िशियस बहुत कम सोचती है। सोच ही नहीं
सकती। ए जॉब अपेंट कम्युनिकेटिंग विद एचआर
इज ए नॉर्मल बिजनेस प्रोसेस। क्योंकि जब
भी कोई स्टूडेंट या कोई भी जॉब के लिए
अप्लाई करता है तो वह किसी भी एचआर के साथ
कम्युनिकेशन करना एक नेचुरल प्रोसेस है।
एक नॉर्मल बिजनेस प्रोसेस है कि भाई वह
अपने एचआर के साथ तो कम्युनिकेशन करेगा ही
करेगा। तो यहीं पर आपका प्री टेक्स्ट
स्टार्ट होता है। दिस इज वेयर प्लानिंग
बिकम्स मोरेंट।
अभी जब
अगर आप एक बिगिनियर हो जैसे कि मैंने आप
लोगों से अभी सवाल पूछा बिकॉज़ यू आर ए
बिगिनियर यू डोंट नो एनीथिंग अबाउट डू सच
थिंग्स। आपको नहीं पता ये चीजें करने का।
आप एक प्रोफेशनल नहीं हो। तो आप क्या
करोगे? यहीं पर गलत डायरेक्शन में जाओगे।
जैसे यहां पर भैया ने बोला एक ने कि हम
मालवेर भेज देंगे। मोहम्मद ने मेला कैसे
भेज दो? बिकॉज़ यह गलत डायरेक्शन आपका टैक
फेल हो गया। आपकी पूरी पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग जर्नी य पर खत्म।
दैट्स ऑल 100% फेल। बिकॉज़ आपको नहीं पता
था। क्योंकि यही वो फेज होता है जहां जहां
से आपको अपना दिमाग ओपन करना पड़ता है।
माइंड ओपन करना पड़ता है। आइडियाज आपके
पास होने चाहिए। आपके पास थोड़ा सा एक
एक्सपीरियंस होना चाहिए। अगर जिंदगी में
आपने कभी भी रियल पेंट टेस्टिंग सिनेरियो
नहीं सुने होंगे, नहीं देखे होंगे, नहीं
किए होंगे, आपके पास कोई एक्सपीरियंस होगा
ही नहीं। तो आपको पता ही नहीं कि मुझे अब
यहां से क्या करना है। मैं कुछ भी हां
अंधेरे में तीर चलाऊंगा। जो अभी बात की गई
थी, अंधेरे में तीर चलाने की बात हुई थी।
नहीं करना ऐसा। यहां पर आपको क्या करना
है? प्लानिंग के साथ हर सवाल जवाब खुद से
सवाल भी करने हैं और जवाब भी खुद को ही
देना है। यह हो गया तो यह यह हो गया। हर
एक का आपके पास प्लान प्लानिंग आपको यहां
पर करनी है। दैट इज योर प्लानिंग फेज। तो
यही वह प्लानिंग फेज है कि प्रोफेशनल
पेंटेस्टर्स डज नॉट रेंडमली सेंड फाइल्स
और मैसेजेस। कभी भी एक कोई भी प्रिंट्रेशन
टेस्टर प्रोफेशनल पे टेस्ट होता है वो कभी
भी डायरेक्टली किसी रैंडम फाइल्स या
मैसेजेस नहीं करेगा। बिकॉज़ उसको एक
अपॉर्चुनिटी मिली है कांटेक्ट करने की और
जो बिल्कुल ही एक लेजिटमेट अपॉर्चुनिटी
है। वो उसको कभी भी खोने की कोशिश नहीं
करेगा। चाहे उसको बाद में ही क्यों ना यूज़
करे। दी टेस्टर फर्स्ट आइडेंटिफाई ए
रियलिस्टिक बिजनेस कांटेक्ट अंडरस्टैंड हु
मे रिसीव द कम्युनिकेशन एंड इंश्योर दैट
एक्टिविटी स्टे विद इन द अप्रूव्ड रूल ऑफ
इंगेजमेंट बिल्कुल और यह सारी चीजें आपको
दायरे में होनी चाहिए स्कोप के अंदर होनी
चाहिए कुछ भी आउट ऑफ स्कोप यहां भी चीज
नहीं जानी चाहिए नेक्स्ट स्टेप टू क्या है
आपका आपका स्टेप टू है इनिशिएटिंग
कांटेक्ट जिसकी हमने बात की अब नितेश थे
भैया प्रोफेशनल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स
उन्होंने क्या किया नितेश क्रिएट ए
पिकटीएस पर्सनल परसना नेम नितेश जॉनसन एंड
सबमिट ए रिज्यूम टू एकमी कॉरपोरेशन
वेबसाइट यूजिंग द रिज्यूम
रिज्यूुमे अपलोड फीचर्स ठीक है भैया नितेश
ने क्या किया कि एक फेक आइडेंटिटी क्रिएट
की और फेक आइडेंटिटी किस नाम से क्रिएट की
नितेश जॉनसन और उसने क्या किया नितेश
जॉनसन की प्रोफाइल से कंपनी के पोर्टल पर
जॉब एपिकेंट अप्लाई की और जो उसका
रिज्यूमे था जो उसकी सीवीज थी वो अपलोड कर
दी। बट
यहां पर आता है आपका टेक्निकल ट्विस्ट।
सीवी तो उसने अपलोड की है बट यहां पर वो
टेक्निकल ट्विस्ट है। द रिज्यूुमे कंटेंस
एन एम्बिडेड मैक दैट ट्रिगर एन एरर व्हेन
ओपन सिमुलेटिंग ए करप्टेड डॉक्यूमेंट। द
पर्पज इज नॉट टू डिप्लॉय मालवेयर स्टिल
डाटा और गेन अन ऑथराइज एक्सेस। इंस्टेड द
पर्पस इज टू ट्रिगर द रियलिस्टिक सपोर्ट
स्टाइल रिस्पांस फ्रॉम द रिसीविंग एंप्लई।
भैया एक बात बताओ ना सामने से कांटेक्ट
आना चाहिए ना। कैसे आएगा? एक तो हमें
कंफर्मेशन करना है। हमें अपनी छोटी सी
इनफो चाहिए। दूसरा हमें कांटेक्ट
इस्टैब्लिश करना है। कैसे किया? तो
टेक्निक पार्ट क्या? उसने क्या किया?
रिज्यूुमे के अंदर एक कस्टम एक छोटा सा
मैक था। मै कोड लिखा जो क्या कर रहा था वह
कोई मशियस काम नहीं कर रहा था ना तो कोई
मालवेयर था ना कोई वो रिवर्स सेल
एग्जीक्यूट कर रहा था ना वह आपको रिवर्स
सेल दे रहा था ना वो कोई मालवेयर ना कुछ
डाटा चुरा रहा था कुछ भी नहीं कर रहा था
वो बस वो क्या कर रहा था सिर्फ एक फेक एरर
मैसेज दे रहा था एक विंडोज पॉप अप दे रहा
था जैसे उस फाइल को ओपन किया जाएगा एक एरर
आएगी फाइल करप्टेड या अनरीडेबल
एक रियल मैसेज है ये तो रियलिस्टिक है
बताइए अगर आपने कोई डॉक्यूमेंट ओपन किया
और आपको एक एरर आए कि फाइल करप्टेड एरर और
अनरीडेबल
यह चीज वो क्या कर रहा है? इसके अंदर
जनरेट करवा रहा है उस सीवी के अंदर
जानबूझकर क्योंकि उसको पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट
मिला है। उसको कांटेक्ट इस्टैब्लिश करना
है। अपॉर्चुनिटी है उसके पास। एवरीवन
क्लियर समझ में आया?
स्टेप टू क्लियर है? फेज टू कांटेक्ट कैसे
इनिशिएट किया? सीवी के अंदर जानबूझकर एक
एरर क्रिएट करवाई। एरर में था कि फाइल
करप्टेड और अनइडेबल। जैसे सामने वाली
पार्टी उसको ओपन करेगी फाइल करप्टेड।
नेचुरल प्रोसेस है। फाइल करप्ट हो सकती है
भाई। क्यों नहीं हो सकती? हो सकती है। एक
नेचुरल प्रोसेस है ना? तो वही चीज़ है। तो
स्टेप थ्री आता है अभी आपका फज़ थ्री।
रिस्पांस फ्रॉम द कंपनी एन एचआर एंप्लई एट
एसीजी कॉरपोरेशन अटेमप्ट टू ओपन द सबमिटेड
रिज्यूम रिज्यूमे एंड आफ्टर एनकाउंटरिंग द
एरर मैसेज द एंप्लॉय अ अस्यूम दैट दी फाइल
मे बी करप्टेड और इनकंपैटिबल
अब जब एचआर डिपार्टमेंट में बैठे किसी भी
एक एंप्लॉय ने उस एजुमे को ओपन किया और
ओपन करते ही उसको क्या आया एक एरर आया तो
भैया उसको क्या लगा सच में उसको क्या लगा
कि भैया सच में कोई फाइल में या तो कोई
इनकंपैटिबल है। मेरे सॉफ्टवेयर के साथ ओपन
नहीं हो रही या कोई इशू है फाइल के साथ।
तो जैसे ही एरर आई दी एचआर रिप्रेजेंटेटिव
देन रिसोंड टू द क्लाइंट और जैसे ही एचआर
जो मैनेजर को लगा कि यह टेक्निकल इशू है।
एक जेन्युइन टेक्निकल इशू है। उसने क्या
किया? हाय नितेश। वी रिसीव्ड योर
रिज्यूुमे बट वी आर नॉट एबल टू ओपन इट। इट
सीम्ड करप्टेड। कैन यू प्लीज रीस सबमिट
इट? और जैसे ही उन्होंने क्या किया? नितेश
को जो नितेश किसको किया? नितेश जॉनसन को।
नितेश जॉनसन कौन था? जिसके पास एक फेक
प्रोफाइल थी उसके ऊपर एक ईमेल भेजा कि
भैया नितेश आपने जो रिज्यूे मुझे सबमिट
किया था वो हम उसको ओपन नहीं कर पा रहे
नहीं देख पा रहे। वो करप्ट कर रहा है। तो
क्या उसको रीसमिट कर सकते हो? बस सिंपल
पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट इस्टैब्लिश हो गया। दिस
रिस्पांस गिव नितेश द फर्स्टेंट पीस ऑफ
इंटेलिजेंस। तो पॉइंट नंबर वन यहीं पर अब
नितेश को बिना किसी डाउट के एक चीज तो
कंफर्म हो गई कि जो कंपनी है वह Microsoft
Office का यूज कर रही है। मतलब कंपनी में
Microsoft Office इंस्टॉल्ड है और जो एचआर
डिपार्टमेंट है उसको एक्टिवली यूज़ कर रहा
है। वन पीस ऑफेंट इंफॉर्मेशन इज कंफर्म्ड
फ्रॉम जस्ट ए सिंपल एरर जस्ट ए सिंपल
रिज्यूे।
दी कंपनी एचआर टीम इज एक्टिवली ओपनिंग
रिज्यूे अटैचमेंट सबमिटेड थ्रू द पोर्टल।
दिस कंफर्म द डॉक्यूमेंट हैज़ रीच्ड रियल
यूजर। सेकंड कंफर्मेशन क्या हुई? एक रियल
यूजर के वो पास गई है। एंड थर्ड वन द
रिक्रूटमेंट वर्क फ्लो इनवॉल्व्स मैनुअल
डॉक्यूमेंट हैंडलिंग। तीसरी चीज क्या
होगी? कि वह मैनुअल डॉक्यूमेंट हैंडलिंग
परफॉर्म कर रहे हैं। इन ए क्लाइंट साइड
असेसमेंट दिस इज़ अ वैल्यूुएबल इनेशन। इट
टेल द टेस्टर द ऑर्गेनाइजेशन हैज ए ह्यूमन
ड्रिवन डॉक्यूमेंट रिव्यु प्रोसेस एंड देन
एचआर एंप्लॉय इंटक्ट विद एक्सटर्नली
सबमिटेड फाइल्स ऑब्वियसली यहां तक आई होप
सबको क्लियर हो गया कि मैं व्हाट आई एम
ट्राइंग टू से और व्हाट आई एम ट्राइंग टू
कन्व
कन्व टू यू मैं आपको क्या बताने की कोशिश
कर रहा हूं। स्टेप नंबर फोर फेज नंबर फोर
क्या है? एक्सप्लइटिंग द अपॉर्चुनिटी। अब
आपके पास एक सामने एक अपोरर्चुनिटी है।
ओके? आपके सामने एक अपॉर्चुनिटी है। आफ्टर
रिसीविंग द एचआर रिस्पांस नितेश रिप्लाई
पोलाइटली एंड प्रोफेशनली। इंस्टेड ऑफ
आस्किंग एनीथिंग सस्िशियस ही फ्रेम द
क्वेश्चंस अराउंड कंपैटिबिलिटी। अब नितेश
को जैसे ही ईमेल मिलता है, वह तुरंत
रिसोंड करता है, लेकिन वह जल्दबाजी में
रिसोंड नहीं करता। वह बहुत ही पोलाइट और
प्रोफेशनल तरीके से एक कंसर्न एक्सप्रेस
करते हुए कंसर्न बोल रहा हूं। चिंता
व्यक्त करते हुए साथ में एक छोटा सा
बिल्कुल ही कॉमन सवाल पूछ लेता है कि जैसे
कि हो आई एम एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी फॉर
इनकन्वीनियंस इनक्वीनियंस। कैन यू प्लीज
लेट मी नो व्हिच वर्जन ऑफ Microsoft Word
और डॉक्यूमेंट व्यूअर योर टीम इज यूजिंग
बिकॉज़ आई वांट टू मेक श्योर माय नेक्स्ट
सबमिशन ओपन प्रॉपर्ली ऑन योर सिस्टम्स। अब
यह चीज है। इस चीज में कुछ भी सस्िशियस
आपको लग रहा है?
क्या इस चीज में कुछ भी सस्िशियस आपको लग
रहा है? नहीं है कुछ भी सस्पिशियस।
और यह दिस मैसेज वर्क्स बिकॉज़ इट फिस
नेचुरली इन द कॉन्टेक्स्ट बिकॉज़ ए जॉब
एपिकेंट आस्किंग अबाउट डॉक्यूमेंट
कंपैटिबिलिटी आफ्टर ए रिज्यूुमे फेल्स टू
ओपन डज़ नॉट सीम अनयूजुअल यह कुछ भी
अनयूजुअल चीज नहीं है।
नहीं यार एक चीज है कॉस्मिक बाइट 814
यह अस्यूम नहीं कर रहे ना आप नॉर्मल
सिनेरियो होता है किसी भी आप जॉब ओपनिंग
जहां पर आप जॉब अप्लाई करके देखो आप
एप्लीकेशन भेजो और वहीं पे करप्टेड फाइल
भेजो डेफिनेटली आपके पास मैसेज या कॉल आता
है पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट सामने से होता है ये
तो बिल्कुल नेचुरल प्रोसेस है इसमें कुछ
भी एजम्पशन नहीं है बिल्कुल नेचुरल
प्रोसेस है
आता है कॉल कॉल नहीं तो ईमेल आएगा आएगा
बिल्कुल आता है।
तो नेक्स्ट
नाउ दिस इज द कोर ऑफ इफेक्टिव
प्रीटेक्स्टिंग। मतलब यही आप एक छोटा सा
एक नमूना है। एक छोटा सा एग्जांपल्स है कि
प्रीक्स्टिंग कितनी पावरफुल होती है।
क्योंकि
आपने एक स्टोरी सी क्रिएट की। स्टोरी भी
कहां क्रिएट की? बस एक अपॉर्चुनिटी थी।
जैसे आपको अपॉर्चुनिटी दिखी आपने बस सवाल
पूछ दिया समय को देखते हुए और वह भी नॉन
सस्िशियस वे में ओके तो गुड प्री टेस्टिंग
डज नॉट रिलाई ऑन फर्स्ट फॉर टेक्निकल
एक्सप्लइटेशन कभी भी जो प्री टेक्स्टिंग
होती है कभी भी टेक्निकल एक्सप्लॉयटेशन पे
कभी काम नहीं करती हमेशा टाइमिंग पर
ट्रस्ट पर और नॉर्मल बिजनेस बिहेवियर पर
ही वह काम करती है वह चीजें आपको आनी
चाहिए अब आता है पेज फाइव लाइफ इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग एकमी कॉरपोरेशन एचआर
रिप्रेजेंटेटिव अनअवेयर ऑफ द मिलिशियस
इंटेंट रिसोंड टू द नितेश इंक्वायरी
प्रोवाइडिंग डिटेल्स अबाउट द कंपनीज़
Microsoft Word वर्जन एंड सच सेज़ नो
प्रॉब्लम नितेश वी आर यूजिंग Microsoft
Word 2019 या सो वर्जन ऑन Windows 10 एंड
दिस रिस्पांस गिव द टेस्टरेंट क्लाइंट
साइड इंटेलिजेंस अब जो एचआर रिप्रेजेंटिव
था जिसको बिल्कुल भी इस चीज के अनअवेयर था
कि सामने एक एथिकल हैकर बैठा है और
हेल्पफुल बनने के चक्कर में रिसोंड कर
देता है कि नहीं भाई कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं।
हम क्या कर रहे हैं? Microsoft का यह
वर्जन यूज़ कर रहे हैं और यह विंडो यूज़
कर रहे हैं। मतलब भला करने के चक्कर में
उसको बिल्कुल भी इस चीज का पता नहीं था कि
सामने कौन है। अब नितेश को बिना किसी
नेटवर्क पैकेट के सिंगल नेटवर्क पैकेट
उसको भेजना नहीं पड़ा। उसको एग्जैक्ट एक
एक्यूरेट 100% वैलिड इंफॉर्मेशन मिल गई।
पता चल गया। कुछ मेहनत ही नहीं करनी पड़ी।
जस्ट एक पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट इस्टैब्लिश
करना पड़ा जिससे बातचीत करनी पड़ी। इससे
एक्यूरेट इनफेशन कहीं नहीं मिलेगी। हर जगह
सोचते रहते हैं। इससे एक्यूरेट इन कहीं
नहीं मिलती। ओके? तो फ्रॉम ए रेट टीम
पर्सपेक्टिव दीज़ आर यूज़फुल डेटा पॉइंट्स
फ्रॉम ए डिफेंसिव पर्सपेक्टिव दे हाईलाइट
हाउ एंप्लॉय मे अनइटेंशनली डिस्क्लोज
टेक्निकल डिटेल्स। बिल्कुल सही बात है।
डिफेंसिव पर्सपेक्टिव से देखें तो एंप्लई
को पता भी नहीं रहता कब वो बातोंबातों में
ऐसी चीजें सामने वाली पार्टी के सामने
डिस्क्लोज कर देता है जो उसके लिए एक
नॉर्मल बात आम बातचीत है। लेकिन जो सामने
है उसके लिए दिस इज वेरी वेरीेंट
इंफॉर्मेशन जैसे कि हमारे केस में बिल्कुल
तो नेक्स्ट हमारा आता है फेज सिक्स। अब
हमारे पास इंफॉर्मेशन है। नाउ नितेश नाउ
इक्विप विद इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट एकमी
कॉरपोरेशन माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड वर्जन
यूज दिस इंफॉर्मेशन टू आइडेंटिफाई
पोटेंशियल वनबिलिटीज और कंपैटिबिलिटी इशूज़
एंड ही मे आल्सो यूज़ इट टू टेलर फ्यूचर
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक्स और क्राफ्ट
मिलसियस पेलोड्स टारगेटिंग स्पेसिफिक
सॉफ्टवेयर वर्जनंस मिलसियस वर्ड
डॉक्यूमेंट। अब नितेश के पास प्योर डाटा
पॉइंट्स हैं। वह क्या करेगा? इंटरनेट पर
चेक करेगा कि इस पर्टिकुलर या स्पेसिफिक
वर्जन में कौन-कौन सी सिक्योरिटी
कंट्रोल्स एक्टिव हैं। कौन-कौन सी
वीकनेसेस हैं और वो इस स्पेसिफिक वर्जन के
मुताबिक अपना फाइनल पेलोड डिजाइन करेगा।
और उसके बाद क्या होगा? वह उसका पेलोड
100% काम करेगा। बिकॉज़ उसकी रिसर्च सारी
चीजें उसने की है। उसके बाद इसको उसने
परफॉर्म किया है फेज सिक्स को। ओके? तो
अगर हम बात करें कि आपने अगर इस पूरे अटैक
सीक्वेंस को एनालाइज किया होगा या एक काम
करो आप इस पूरे अटैक सीक्वेंस को एनालाइज
करो और सोचो नितेश ने ऐसा क्या किया कि यह
पूरा प्रोसेस इतना स्मूथ हो गया। क्या कोई
मुझे यह बताएगा कि उसने ऐसा क्या किया है?
इस पूरे छह के छह फेज में कि यह प्रोसेस
इतनी आसान है और इतनी वैल्यूएबल
इंफॉर्मेशन के लिए इतनी आसान प्रोसेस
होगी। एनीवन कोई समराइज करना चाहेगा इस
चीज को कोई भी
कोई भी
थोड़ा सा तो मुझे हिंट करो ना थोड़ा सा
लिखो यार
कितनी तो मेहनत कर लो
और कुछ
अभिषेक और कुछ
आप कोशिश अच्छी कर रहे हो प्राइम मोर
बताइए
नहीं उसने ट्रस्ट क्या गेन किया नो ट्रस्ट
कहां गेन किया है नो
ओके राइट मोहम्मद पॉइंट नंबर वन इज करेक्ट
देखिए उसकी थी परफेक्ट प्री टेक्स्टिंग
मतलब एक जॉब एपिकेंट का एचआर के साथ
बातचीत करना और
कंपैटिबिलिटी इशू के बारे में पूछना
बिल्कुल आम बात है।
सब एग्री करते हो कि एक कोई भी चाहे भले
ही आप हो तो कहीं पर आप जॉब अप्लाई कर रहे
हो और उसके एचआर से आप बात कर रहे हो और
एक कंपैटिबिलिटी इशू के ऊपर टॉपिक है तो
बिल्कुल आम बिहेवियर नहीं होगा यह नॉर्मल
बिहेवियर क्या इसमें थोड़ा सा भी आपको लग
सकता है 1% भी चांस कि यहां कुछ सस्पिशियस
है
लगता है किसी को यहां कुछ सस्िशियस हो भी
सकता है
बताओ
नहीं लग सकता ना यही थी वह परफेक्ट प्री
टेक्स्टिंग सही समय पर सही चीज का यूज
करना सही दिमाग का यूज करना यह था सबसे
पहली चीज दूसरी
उसके बाद अब क्या है कि नितेश को शूटिंग
इन द डार्क नहीं करना पड़ेगा अंधेरे में
तीर नहीं चलाना पड़ेगा क्योंकि जब नितेश
रियल वेपनाइज पेलोड का यूज करेगा ठीक ठीक
है? जब वो असली पेलोड यूज़ करेगा तो उसका
पेलोड फेल नहीं होगा क्योंकि उसे पता है
सामने Microsoft Office इंस्टॉल्ड है।
Microsoft Word है। यह वर्जन है और उसका
पेलोड फेल नहीं होगा। परफेक्टली काम करेगा
और उसके
चांसेस ज्यादा हो जाते हैं रेदर देन
ब्लाइंडली ट्राई करने के। उसके सक्सेस
स्ट्रेन के चांसेस उस नॉर्मल चांस से बहुत
ज्यादा हो जाते हैं।
देखिए फेंटेस्टिंग में सिनेरियो
टू सिनेरियो चीजें बदलती हैं। यह जस्ट एक
छोटा सा सिनेरियो था कि एक बिल्कुल कॉमन
सिनेरियो हर बार यह थोड़ी ना मिलेगा। वो
तो आपको सोचना पड़ेगा। आपको दिमाग लगाना
पड़ेगा। आपको अपना एक्सपीरियंस यूज़ करना
पड़ेगा। ये चीजें कहां कैसे कहां से आती
है? आपको एक्सपीरियंस से आती है। यह आपकी
स्किल से आती है। यह आपकी थिंकिंग
कैपेबिलिटी से आती है कि आप कितने
एक्स्ट्रा ऑर्डिनरी हो। आप शॉर्ट टाइम में
कितना जल्दी डिसीजन ले पाते हो। या जब आप
ऐसी चीजें करने की सोच रहे हो तो आप पहले
से प्रिपेयर हो। ऐसा हुआ तो यह करूंगा,
ऐसा हुआ तो यह करूंगा और यह नहीं हुआ तो
यह और कई बार तीनों ही नहीं होंगे। तो
सडनली उसके लिए भी आपको तैयार रहना पड़ेगा
कि अब मैं क्या करूं? दैट इज दैट वन थिंग।
क्लियर है एवरीवन यहां तक सारी चीजें सबको
समझ में आ गई।
यहां तक सबको समझ में आ गया?
गुड एवरीवन। चलिए नेक्स्ट।
यह सबको क्लियर है? अब चलते हैं हम
क्लाइंट फिंगरप्रिंटिंग के टॉपिक पर। ठीक
है? क्योंकि देखो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का एक
एग्जांपल हमने ले लिया। हमने यह भी सीख
लिया कि एक छोटे से ह्यूमन टच पॉइंट से
कितनी वैलएबल इंफॉर्मेशन निकाली जा सकती
है। इस पे भी हमने डिस्कस कर लिया। अब हम
बढ़ते हैं क्लाइंट फिंगरप्रिंटिंग पे। तो
क्लाइंट प्रिंटिंग। फिंगरप्रिंटिंग होता
क्या है? व्हाट इज क्लाइंट
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग? क्लाइंट फिंगरप्रिंटिंग
इज एन एक्टिव क्लाइंट इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
टेक्निक यूज टू गैदर इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट ए
टारगेट सिस्टम्स वेब ब्राउज़र एंड अंडरलाइन
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इन ऑर्डर टू ऐड इन द
डेवलपमेंट ऑफ क्लाइंट स्पेसिफिक पेलोड फॉर
इनिशियल एक्सेस क्लाइंट फिंगरप्रिंट एक
एक्टिव इंफॉर्मेशनेशन गैदरिंग टेक्निक है
जिसका यूज़ करके हम टारगेट के वेब
ब्राउज़र्स और उसके अंडरलाइन ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम की एग्जैक्ट इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट
कर सकते हैं, निकाल सकते हैं। द क्लाइंट
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग प्लेज़ एनेंट रोल इन द
सक्सेस ऑफ क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स एज इट
प्रोवाइड्स द टैकर विद एक्यूरेट इनेशन ऑफ
द क्लाइंट साइड सॉफ्टवेयर रनिंग ऑन द
टारगेट एंड एंप्लाइजज़ कंप्यूटरटर्स। यह
कुछ पॉइंट है। आपके लिए अब वैल्यू महत्व
रखते नहीं क्योंकि ये सिनेरियो मैंने आपको
बता दिया क्योंकि इसका मेन गोल होता है
क्लाइंट स्पेसिफिक पेलोड डिजाइन करना।
क्लाइंट स्पेसिफिक पेलोड डिजाइन करने में
हेल्प करना और अगर आपको इनिशियल एक्सेस
चाहिए तो आपको यह पता होना चाहिए कि पेलोड
किस एनवायरमेंट में एग्जीक्यूट होने वाला
है और यह इंफॉर्मेशन कहां से आएगी आपको?
क्लाइंट फिंगरप्रिंटिंग से ही आएगी। और
हमारे लिए तीन इनेशन बहुत ज्यादा मैटर
करती है। कौन सी? ब्राउज़र, ब्राउज़र का
नाम, उसका वर्जन, उसका ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम और
आर्किटेक्चर। ये तो बिल्कुल ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट है हमारे लिए बहुत ज्यादा
मीनिंगफुल है। नाउ इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट द
टारगेट एंप्लाइजज़ कंप्यूटर इज टिपिकली नॉट
पब्लिकली एक्सेसबल एंड एज ए रिजल्ट वी
मस्ट ऑब्टेंड दिस इंफॉर्मेशन फ्रॉम द
टारगेट सिस्टम इटसेल्फ। अब यह जो इंटरनल
सिस्टम कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस की इंफॉर्मेशन होती
है, वह कभी भी इंटरनेट पर अवेलेबल नहीं
होती। कभी भी पब्लिकली आपको अवेलेबल नहीं
मिलेगी इंटरनेट पर। इसका मतलब आपको क्या
करना पड़ेगा? आपको यह जानकारी डायरेक्टली
किससे लेनी पड़ेगी? आपको टारगेट सिस्टम
टारगेट एंप्लई से ही लेनी पड़ेगी। और
टारगेट एंप्लॉय की जो मशीन है उसी से ही
वह इंफॉर्मेशन पुल करनी पड़ेगी। दिस
इनवॉल्व्स यूटिलाइजिंग सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
टेक्निक्स लाइक फिशिंग टू कोहर्स द टारगेट
एंप्लॉय इनू क्लिकिंग ए लिंक टू ए वेब
एप्लीकेशन वेब पेज दैट वी कंट्रोल। अब
आपको क्या करना है कि यह तो चीज आपको पता
है कि यह इंफॉर्मेशन पुल करने के लिए सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग टेक्निक का यूज करना पड़ेगा।
लेकिन हमेशा हमेशा एक एक काम करना हमें
बिल्कुल भी नॉन नॉन सस्िशियस रहना है।
हमें हमेशा क्या करना है? नॉन सस्िशियस
रहना है। हमें ऐसी कोई भी गलती नहीं करनी
जिससे किसी भी ब्लू ट्यूमर्स या एंप्लॉय
को अलर्ट चला जाए। एंप्लॉय को शक हो जाए
कि नहीं कोई कुछ गलत करने की कोशिश कर रहा
है तो आपको पूरा नॉन सस्पिशियस तरीके से
कांटेक्ट एस्टैब्लिश करना है इनिशिएट करना
है शक नहीं होना चाहिए ओके नेक्स्ट दिस
वेब ब्राउज़र व्हिच टिपिकली बी कॉन्फिगर
टू रन ए स्क्रिप्ट दैट ऑब्टेन इनेशन लाइक
द ब्राउज़र वर्जन ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम वर्जन
फ्रॉम द ब्राउज़र एट्रा ब्ल ब्ल ब्ल ये
चीज आपको पता है अह वाई डम वेरी गुड
इवनिंग ब्रो
ओके नेक्स्ट
अब आते हैं हम ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग पर।
अब आते हैं ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग पर और
आज मैं आपको एक ऐसी चीज बताने वाला हूं यह
चीज कि डेली बेसिस पर ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग लीगल वे में यूज़ की जाती
है। इफ यू आर नॉट अवेयर। ठीक है? और हम
इसको सोशल यूज़िंग के लिए यूज़ करते हैं।
डेली ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग अभी भी आपके
सिस्टम में ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग कहीं
ना कहीं यूज़ हो रही होगी। देखो
व्हेन पीपल थिंक अबाउट ऑनलाइन प्राइवेसी
द फर्स्ट कांसेप्ट दैट यूजली कम टू माइंड
आर कुकीज़ इन कॉग्निटो मोड वीपीएस और
क्लियरिंग ब्राउज़र हिस्ट्री। मेनी यूज़र्स
बिलीव दैट डिलीटिंग कुकीज़ और ब्राउजिंग
प्राइवेटली इज़ एनफ टू रिमेन अनोनिमस
ऑनलाइन। नॉर्मली जब भी हम ऑनलाइन
प्राइवेसी की बात करते हैं तो सबके दिमाग
में सबसे पहले क्या आता है? कुकेज इन
ब्राउज़र में इनकॉग्निटो मोड वीपीएंस या हम
ब्राउज़र हिस्ट्री को डिलीट कर देते हैं।
क्लियर कर देते हैं। राइट? यही सबके दिमाग
में आता होगा। बट लेट मी टेल यू आज की डेट
में हाउएवर इन टुडेेज़ डिजिटल लैंडस्केप
अचीविंग कंप्लीट एनोनिमिटी इज़ बिकमिंग
इंक्रीजिंगली डिफिकल्ट। एंड वन ऑफ द
प्राइमरी रीजन फॉर दिस इज ए सोफोस्टिकेटेड
ट्रैकिंग टेक्निक नोन एज ब्राउज़र
प्रिंटिंग। आज की डेट में एब्सोल्यूट
एनोनिमिटी मेंटेन करना नेक्स्ट टू
इंपॉसिबल है और उसकी सबसे बड़ी वजह है आपका
ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग। कैसे? ट्रेडिशनल
ट्रैकिंग मेथड्स दैट रियलाइज़ ऑन कुकीज़।
ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग कैन आइडेंटिफाई
एंड ट्रैक यूजर बेस्ड ऑन यूनिक
कैरेक्टरिस्टिक्स ऑफ़ देयर डिवाइसेस एंड
ब्राउज़र्स। जो भी आप ब्राउज़र यूज करते हो,
जो भी डिवाइसेस यूज करते हो, उसकी यूनिक
कैरेक्टरिस्टिक्स की वजह से ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंट आपको आइडेंटिफाई और ट्रैक कर
सकता है। कभी भी सुना होगा आपने जब टोर
ब्राउज़र यूज़ करते हो, उसको फुल स्क्रीन पे
मत यूज़ करो। बिकॉज़
ट्रैक हो जाते हो। यही वही कारण है बिकॉज़
ऑफ़ ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग। और जब यह टर्म
आपको शायद नहीं पता थी तो पता कर लो।
क्योंकि जब इसको लीगल तरीके से यूज़ किया
मैं आपको बताऊंगा। तो एज ए रिजल्ट इवन
प्राइवेसी कश कॉन्शियस यूज़र्स मे
अननोइंगली लिव बिहाइंड ए रिकॉग्नाइज़ेबल
डिजिटल आइडेंटिटी एवरी टाइम दे विजिट ए
वेबसाइट। भले आप कितने ही प्राइवेसी
कंसर्न हो आप जाने या अनजाने में जब भी आप
कोई भी वेबसाइट यूज़ करते हो तो आप अपनी
डिजिटल आइडेंटिटी वहां पर छोड़ जाते हो।
डिजिटल पहचान वहां पर आप छोड़ के जाते ही
हो। नाउ फॉर एग्जांपल अभी समझते हैं हम
इसको एक एनालॉजी से एक एनालॉजी इमेजिन
करते हैं। फॉर एग्जांपल क्या करते हैं?
इमेजिन कीजिए कि आप एक कॉफी शॉप यह आपका
कॉफी शॉप है और यह एक व्यक्ति है जो कॉफी
शॉप में बस घूमने जाता है और कॉफी पीने
जाता है। और जो वहां का जो स्टाफ है वह
कभी भी आपको बायोफेस नहीं जानता। फिर भी
वो कैसे जानता है? बाय फेस जानता नहीं।
लेकिन फिर भी वह जानता है। कैसे? क्योंकि
वो रिकॉर्ड वो क्या करता है? आपके जो
ओवरऑल स्ट्रक्चर है, आपके जो ओवरऑल स्टाइल
है, उसको रिकॉग्नाइज कर लेता है। जैसे
आपके आप नॉर्मली कौन सी वॉच का मॉडल यूज़
करते हो? कौन से शूज आप पहनते हो? क्या
आपकी पर्सनालिटी है? कौन सा आप परफ्यूम
यूज़ करते हो? कैसे तरीके से आप अपना ऑर्डर
ऑर्डर करते हो? किस तरीके से आप किसके साथ
डील करते हो? कैसे उनके स्टाफ के साथ आप
डील करते हो? आपकी ये सारी जो चीजें हैं
ना, यह उनके मन में बैठ जाती है। उनके
रिकॉग्नाइजेशन पैटर्न में बैठ जाती है।
ओके? और जैसे ही नेक्स्ट टाइम जब उनके
रेस्टोरेंट में जाते हो आप क्या होता है?
नेक्स्ट टाइम आप उनके रेस्टोरेंट में जाते
हो क्या होता है? अगर आपने थोड़ा बहुत
अपना आउटपुट चेंज भी कर लिया ना तब भी वो
आपको पहचान जाते हैं आपकी आदतों से, आपकी
वो स्टाइल से, आपके लुक से क्योंकि सारी
चीजें तो आप चेंज नहीं करते। थोड़ा बहुत
ही चेंज करते हो। तो लाइक जैसे आप क्या
करते हो कि भैया मुझे एक काम करता हूं
ब्राउज़र में कुछ काम कर रहा हूं। मैं एक
काम करता हूं थोड़ी सी प्राइवेसी मेंटेन
करने के लिए इग्न इनकॉग्निटो मोड यूज़ कर
लेता हूं। लेकिन ऐसा थोड़ी ना है कि आप
थोड़ा सा अपना आउटपुट चेंज कर लोगे या
आउटपुट चेंज कर लोगे या थोड़ा सा
ब्राउजर्स का पैटर्न चेंज कर लोगे तो आपकी
आइडेंटिटी बदल जाएगी। नहीं इनकॉग्निटो मोड
में भी आपकी आइडेंटिटी नहीं बदलती। आपको
ऐसा लगता है कि मैं अगर ब्राउज़र को सर्व
ब्राउज करूंगा इनकॉग्निटो मोड में और मेरी
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग बदल जाएगी। यह दिमाग से
निकाल देना। इनकॉग्निटो मोड में भी
ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग नहीं बदलती।
एक्यूरेट रहती है। किसी को लगता है कि मैं
प्राइवेसी मेंटेन कर पाऊंगा? नो भैया नो
मेंटेन इग्नोटिव मोड में भी अगर ढंग का
फिंगरप्रिंटर्स किसी ने डिजाइन किया हुआ
है ना वो तब भी रिकॉग्नाइज कर लेगा कि
नहीं सेम लैपटॉप है सेम सेम मशीन है कोई
बदलाव नहीं है नो नो नो नो बिल्कुल
डेफिनेटली तो यह था अब एक छोटा सा
एग्जांपल नाउ बिल्कुल सेम ब्राउज़र में भी
ऐसा होता है दिस इज एसेंशियली हाउ ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंट इसी प्रकार से जो ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग भी काम करती है व्हेन यू
ब्राउज़ द इंटरनेट वेबसाइट्स कलेक्ट
न्यूमरस स्माल पीसेस ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट
योर डिवाइसेस एंड ब्राउज़र्स। क्या होता
है? जब भी आप क्या करते हो इंटरनेट पे
इंटरनेट को ब्राउज़ करते हो, वेबसाइट को
यूज़ करते हो, वेबसाइट बहुत सारी छोटी-छोटी
इनेशन क्रैक करती है आपके ब्राउज़र से,
आपके डिवाइसेस से और वो सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
मिलके क्या करती है? एक हाईली
डिस्टिंक्टिव प्रोफाइल क्रिएट करती है जो
सिर्फ उस पूरे इंटरनेट पर आप ही की होगी।
उस पूरे इंटरनेट पर आप ही लैपटॉप की और आप
ही डिवाइसेस की होगी। वह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
मिलके वह आइडेंटिटी क्रिएट करती है।
क्योंकि एक सिंगल आइडेंटिटी इसमें कुछ
मैटर नहीं करती। कंबाइंड एडटी बहुत कुछ
मैटर करती है। नाउ व्हाट इज ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग? तो ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग क्या होता है? तो अभी बात
करते हैं ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग की।
ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग इज एन एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग टेक्निक दैट लेवरेज
क्लाइंट साइड स्क्रिप्टिंग लैंग्वेज लाइक
जावास्क्रिप्ट टू एक्सट्रैक्ट इंफॉर्मेशन
अबाउट द टारगेट ब्राउज़र एंड अंडरलाइन
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम जो ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग है वह एक एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन गैदरिंग टेक्निक है जो क्या
करती है जो क्लाइंट साइड स्क्रिप्टिंग
लैंग्वेज है कौन सी है क्लाइंट
स्क्रिप्टिंग लैंग्वेज जावास्क्रिप्ट
जावास्क्रिप्ट का यूज़ करती है और उसका यूज़
करते हुए टारगेट ब्राउज़ ब्राउज़र और उसके
अंडरलाइन जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है उसके बारे
में इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट करती है। ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग इज अ ट्रैकिंग टेक्निक दैट
गैदर्स इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट ए यूज़र्स ब्राउज़र
डिवाइस सिस्टम कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस टू क्रिएट ए
यूनिक आइडेंटिफायर
ऑफन रेफर्ड टू एज ए डिजिटल फिंगरप्रिंट
एंड अनलाइक कुकीज़ व्हिच स्टोर मोर
इंफॉर्मेशन स्टोर इंफॉर्मेशन सॉरी करेक्शन
व्हिच स्टोर इंफॉर्मेशनेशन ऑन ए यूजर
डिवाइस फिंगरप्रिंटिंग रिलाइज ऑन द कलेक्ट
कलेक्टिंग एनवायरमेंट कैरेक्टर ब्ल वाला
वाला ठीक है मैं आपको समझाने को अब
वेबसाइट को आपको ट्रैक करने के लिए हमेशा
कुकी की जरूरत नहीं होती। ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग एक ऐसी टेक्निक है जिसमें
वेबसाइट आपके डिवाइस और ब्राउज़र के
छोटे-छोटे स्मालस्मॉल इंफॉर्मेशन या डेटा
पॉइंट को क्या करती है वो? कलेक्ट करती
है। और कैसे कलेक्ट करती है? जब आप किसी
भी वेबसाइट को विजिट करते हो तो उस पेज को
प्रॉपर्ली रेंडर करने के लिए उस पेज को
प्रॉपर्ली डिस्प्ले करने के लिए आपका
ब्राउज़र क्या करता है? ऑटोमेटिकली कुछ
डिटेल्स सर्वर के साथ शेयर करता है और
ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग इसी चीज का फायदा
उठाती है। उसी चीज का बेनिफिट लेती है।
हालांकि एक छोटी सी इंफॉर्मेशन कोई एक
सिंगल डाटा पॉइंट पॉइंट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन कुछ
भी नहीं बिगाड़ सकता। वह बिल्कुल बेकार का
है। लेकिन
अगर उन सारे पैराटर्स को कंबाइन कर दिया
जाए जो पैरामीटर शेयर किए जाते हैं
ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग के लिए तो एक
हाईली प्रोफाइल एक हाईली डिस्टिंक्टिव
प्रोफाइल बन जाती है लाइक ए डीएनए डीएनए
सीक्वेंसिंग मतलब एक प्रॉपर यूनिक
आइडेंटिटी क्रिएट हो जाती है आपकी इंटरनेट
पर ओके तो वो कौन-कौन सी इनेशन उसके लिए
पहले समझते हैं हाउ ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग वर्क्स दी फाउंडेशन ऑफ
ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग इज लार्जली बिल्ट
ऑन जावास्क्रिप्ट। बिल्कुल। अभी आप बोलोगे
सर
जावास्क्रिप्ट ही क्यों यूज़ करते हैं?
बिकॉज़ जावास्क्रिप्ट एग्जीक्यूट लोकली विद
इन द यूजर ब्राउज़र एंड हैज़ एक्सेस टू
वेरियस एस्पेक्ट्स ऑफ द क्लाइंट
एनवायरमेंट। जो जावास्क्रिप्ट है वह वेब
आर्किटेक्चर में में क्लाइंट साइड लोकली
एग्जीक्यूट होती है और वो बहुत सारे क्या
करता है जो लोकल एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल्स
होते हैं बहुत सारे जो लोकल एनवायरमेंट
एनवायरमेंट के जो डेटा होते हैं उनका बहुत
सारा एक्सेस होता है उसके पास उसको बहुत
आसानी से एक्सेस कर सकती है। दैट इज व्हाई
जावास्क्रिप्ट इज द प्राइमरी लैंग्वेज दैट
आर यूज्ड फॉर ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग। दी
जावास्क्रिप्ट कोड कैन एंबेड इन द इंटू द
होम पेज ऑफ द वेबसाइट एंड शुड लॉग एंड
सेंड द ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग ऑफ़ यूज़र्स
हु विजिट द वेब पेजेस। जो जो उसको क्या
करता है? वेब पेजेस को विजिट करता है।
यहां तक सबको क्लियर है?
यहां तक एवरीवन क्लियर है?
यहां तक सबको समझ में आ रहा है?
चलिए आगे बढ़ते हैं कि वह कौन-कौन से डेटा
पॉइंट्स है जो ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग
में कलेक्ट किए जाते हैं। सबसे पहले कौन
सा डाटा पॉइंट आपका? स्क्रीन डायमेंशन एंड
डिस्प्ले इनेशन। आपके मॉनिटर की विड्थ
क्या है? हाइट क्या है? और कल डेप्थ क्या
है? ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इनेशन। आप कौन सी
विंडोज का यूज़ कर रहे हो? कौन से
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का यूज कर रहे हो?
Windows का यूज कर रहे हो, Mac OS का यूज
कर रहे हो, Linis का यूज कर रहे हो,
Android का यूज कर रहे हो, iOS का यूज कर
रहे हो। यूजर एजेंट स्ट्रिंग आपका ब्राउज़र
वर्जन कौन सा है? कौन सा रेंडरिंग वर्जन
रेंडरिंग इंजन यूज़ किया जा रहा है? या
हॉर्स की एग्जैक्ट डिटेल्स इंस्टॉल्ड
फोल्ड मतलब आपके सिस्टम में कौन-कौन से
फोंट्स लोकली इंस्टॉल्ड हैं। ब्राउज़र
एक्सटेंशन एंड प्लगइिंस। मतलब आप कौन-कौन
से प्लगइिंस यूज़ कर रहे हो ब्राउज़र के
अंदर? हो सकता है कि आप अपने ब्राउज़र को
थोड़ा सा और फैशनेट बनाने के लिए कुछ अलग
प्लगिंस यूज कर रहे हो या ऐड ब्लॉकर
प्लगइन यूज कर रहे हो या और कौन-कौन से
प्लगइिंस यूज़ कर रहे हो वो सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग में
कलेक्ट की जा सकती है। हार्डवेयर
स्पेसिफिकेशन मतलब हार्डवेयर स्पेसिफिकेशन
मतलब आपका जो ग्राफिक कार्ड है उसका कौन
सा मॉडल्स है या सीपीू आर्किटेक्चर या
सिस्टम लैंग्वेज सेटिंग क्या है? ये सारी
चीजें आप ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग से बहुत
ही आसानी से पता लगा लगा सकते हैं विद दी
हेल्प ऑफ एनी वेबसाइट और जावास्क्रिप्ट की
हेल्प से। नाउ
अभी बात करते हैं लेजिटमेट यूज़ ऑफ़ ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग। अब ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग इज ऑफन एसोसिएटेड विद
ट्रैकिंग एंड प्राइवेसी कंसर्न्स एंड
हाउएवर इट इज़ नॉट इनहेरेंटली मिलिशियस। अब
इसका मतलब यह नहीं है कि जो ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग है सिर्फ एक मिलिशियस
ट्रैकिंग टूल है। बिल्कुल नहीं है।
ब्राउजिंग ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग का
हमेशा मिलीसियस पर्पस से यूज़ नहीं किया
जाता। इनफैक्ट मेनी ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस रिलाई
ऑन फिंगरप्रिंटिंग फॉर लेजिटमेट
सिक्योरिटी पर्पस। बहुत सारी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
या इवन जो मॉडर्न वेब सिक्योरिटी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस है इसका इसका
मॉडर्न जो वेब सिक्योरिटीज हैं उनमें इसका
बहुत बड़ा रोल्स है। वो इसको सिक्योरिटी
पर्पस से यूज करते हैं। फॉर एग्जांपल जैसे
कि फ्रॉड डिटेक्शन एंड प्रिवेंशन। फ्रॉड
डिटेक्शन एंड प्रिवेंशन। कैसे? जो भी
बैंक्स हैं, जो भी ई-कॉमर्स प्लेटफॉर्म्स
हैं, वह इसका यूज करते हैं फेक अकाउंट्स
और आइडेंटिटी थप से बचाने के लिए। फेक
अकाउंट्स और एंटी थप को डिटेक्ट करने के
लिए। कैसे? फॉर एग्जांपल एक फ्रॉड है,
उसके पास आपका पासवर्ड है। लेकिन अगर
ड्यूरिंग ट्रांजैक्शन ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग मैच नहीं हुई तो क्या
होगा? वो आपको टू फैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन मांग
सकता है। या डिटेक्ट कर लेगा या
ट्रांजक्शन को ब्लॉक कर देगा। ग्रो द
ट्रांजक्शन दैट इज वन पर्पज सेकंड
क्रेडेंशियल स्टफ प्रोटेक्शन के लिए बोट
डिटेक्शन के लिए जैसे कि
किसी ने ऑटोमेटेड स्क्रीन स्क्रिप्ट लगा
रखी है बोट के थ्रू तो वह भी आप ब्राउज़र
फिंगर प्रिंटिंग के थ्रू ईली डिटेक्ट कर
सकते हो। तीसरा अल्टरनेटिव टू कुकीज़। अब
जैसे-जैसे ब्राउज़र थर्ड पार्टी कुकीज को
डेप्रिशिएट कर रहे हैं ड्यू टू प्राइवेसी
लॉज जो एनालिटिक्स कंपनी है वो
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग को को स्टी जो
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग है जो यह ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग है उसको क्या कर रहे हैं?
उसका अल्टरनेटिव मान रहे हैं। उसको
अल्टरनेटिव की तरह देख रहे हैं। इसलिए उस
इस पर्पस से भी उसको यूज़ कर रहे हैं।
नेक्स्ट अब बात करते हैं ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग पेन टेस्टिंग में कैसे
एग्जीक्यूट की जा सकती है?
ठीक है? इसको ड्यूरिंग पेन टेस्ट ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग को आप कैसे यूज़ कर सकते हो
अपने पर्पस के लिए? फ्रॉम ए पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग पर्सपेक्टिव ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग कैन बी यूज्ड ड्यूरिंग
रिकॉन एंड सोशल इंजीनियरिंग इंगेजमेंट टू
गैदर इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट टारगेट एनवायरमेंट।
आप क्या कर सकते हो कि आप ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग का यूज़ कर सकते हो अपने
रिकॉन और सोशल इंजीनियरिंग इंगेजमेंट के
दौरान टारगेट एनवायरमेंट के बारे में
इंफॉर्मेशन निकालने के लिए। उसका वर्क
फ्लो कैसा होगा? सबसे पहले आप क्या करते
हो कि एज ए पेंटेस्टर हमें क्या करता है?
एक जेन्युइन या एक लेजिटमेट या एक रियल
डोमेन परचेस करना पड़ता है और उस डोमेन के
ऊपर हमें क्या करना पड़ता है? एक फेक और
सस्िशियस वेब पेज सेटअप करना पड़ता है।
दूसरा उसके बाद क्या करते हैं हम? उस वेब
पेज के जो वेब पेज हमने सेटअप किया है
उसके होम पेज पर हम एक जावास्क्रिप्ट
एंबेड करते हैं जो क्या करेगी? ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग करेगी जो हमारे लिए वह
इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट करेगी। फिर हम क्या
करेंगे? किसी भी फेसिंग या सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग के जरिए टारगेट एंप्लॉय को को
उस लिंक पर लेकर आएंगे और उस लिंक पर
क्लिक करवाएंगे। फोर्थ वन कौन सा है?
फोर्थ स्टेप क्या होगा आपका? डाटा
कलेक्शन। और जैसे ही एंप्लॉय
ब्राउज़र में उस लिंक पर क्लिक करेगा या
ब्राउज़र में उस पेज पर होम पेज पर क्लिक
करेगा और जैसे ही वह ब्राउज़र रेंडर होगा
क्योंकि जैसे ही आपने क्लिक किया तो
वेबसाइट ओपन होगी ब्राउज़र के अंदर और जैसे
ही वह ब्राउज़र उसको डिस्प्ले करने की
कोशिश करेगा तो बैकग्राउंड में जो
जावास्क्रिप्ट कोड है वह रन करेगा और क्या
करेगा? उसके पूरे ब्राउज़र की जो भी
आइडेंटिटी है, जो भी प्रोफाइल है, वह
निकाल कर हमारे साइड में जो सर्वर्स हमने
सेटअप किया है, उसके ऊपर लॉक की फॉर्म में
स्टोर स्टोर कर देगा। उसको लॉक की फॉर्म
में क्या कर देगा? स्टोर कर देगा। तो यहां
तक सबको क्लियर है?
ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग का मैं प्रैक्टिकल
लेके आऊंगा। डोंट वरी।
क्योंकि
रिसेंटली मैं आपके लिए प्रैक्टिकल आज की
क्लास के लिए प्लान किया था। एक टूल था
फिंगरप्रिंट टू जेएस वो आउटडेटेड हो गया
है और एक फिंगरप्रिंट जेएस है वह
एक लाइब्रेरी है जावा की लाइब्रेरी है एक
प्रो है वो प्रीमियम है और जो फिंगरप्रिंट
js है वो अभी नहीं है तो या तो उसको यूज़
करके या हम एक कस्टमाइज कैसे वह कोड विद
दी हेल्प ऑफ एi डिजाइन कर सकते हैं हमारी
रिक्वायरमेंट के हिसाब से और कैसे हम उसको
प्रैक्टिकली परफॉर्म कर सकते हैं रियली और
किस टाइप की इंफॉर्मेशन हमें देखने को मिल
सकती है वह प्रैक्टिकली मैंने अभी प्लान
कर रहा हूं आप लोगों के लिए ताकि आपको पता
चल जाए कि एक्चुअल में ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग होते कैसे हैं। समझ में आ
गया? डोंट वरी।
ये चीज यहां तक क्लियर है? तो ये कुछ
थ्योरी पार्ट है जो सेम रिपीट कर रहे हैं
इसमें हम। अभी हम बात करते हैं ब्राउज़र
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग के लिए टॉप नाइन टेक्निक
होती है। कुछ नौ टेक्निक का यूज किया जाता
है। वो कौन-कौन सी टेक्निक है मैं आपके
सामने लेके आता हूं। ठीक है? पहले टेक्निक
होती है यह रही कैनवास फिंगरप्रिंटिंग। यह
नौ टेक्निक है जो ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग
में काम आती हैं। और यह सारी की सारी
टेक्निक अगर आपने पढ़ ली एक बार आप खुद से
पढ़ने की कोशिश करना। पर यह सारी की सारी
टेक्निक आपने समझ ली तो आप इनके बेसिस पर
ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग टूल्स बना पाओगे
और उनको यूज भी कर पाओगे। कैनवास
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग
ठीक है? पहली कैनवास फिंगरप्रिंटिंग।
दूसरी आपकी आ गई वेब ग्राफिक लाइब्रेरी।
यह भी फिंगरप्रिंटिंग, ऑडियो
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग, फों्ट फिंगरप्रिंटिंग,
टीसीपीआईपी स्टक फिंगरप्रिंटिंग, स्क्रीन
रेजोल्यूशन फिंगरप्रिंटिंग, हार्डवेयर एंड
परफॉर्मेंस फिंगरप्रिंटिंग, ब्राउज़र
प्लगइन फिंगरप्रिंट, टाइम ज़ोन एंड
लैंग्वेज फिंगरप्रिंटिंग। ये टोटल कुछ नौ
टॉप फिंगरप्रिंटिंग टेक्निक्स है जो आप
ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग में यूज़ कर सकते
हो एस पर योर सिचुएशंस।
ओके? फिंगरप्रिंटिंग से कैसे बचना है उसके
ऊपर लेक्चर चाहिए वो भी मैं लेके आ
जाऊंगा।
डोंट वरी।
कैसे बचा जाए उसकी भी एक टेक्निक्स हैं।
ठीक है? अगर आपको वह टेक्निक्स जाननी है
तो नेक्स्ट क्लास में वह इंक्लूड कर लूंगा
आप लोगों के लिए। ओके?
तो यहां तक सबको क्लियर है? दैट्स ऑल।
दैट्स ऑल। यह चीज क्लियर है सबको?
सबको समझ में आया? प्लीज टेल मी एवरीवन।
सबको यह सारी चीजें समझ में आ गई? मजा आया
लेक्चर में कोई बोर तो नहीं हुआ होगा या
किसी को ऐसा लग रहा है सर नॉट इंटरेस्टेड
मजा नहीं आया चेंज करो
सबको चीजें क्रिस्टल एंड क्लियर मिल गई कि
हम क्या चीज सीख रहे हैं और क्या चीज के
साथ हम डील करने वाले हैं फ्यूचर में कभी
भी
अंकित कुमार क्या पूछना चाह रहे
इसका कब यूज़ है ब्रो? आप क्लास में बहुत
लेट आए हो। आई रिक्वेस्ट क्लास एंड होने
के बाद आप एक काम करना इसको देखना शुरू
से। आपको डेफिनेटली पता चल जाएगा कि कब
इसका यूज़ है।
चलिए फिर अगर किसी का कोई सवाल है तो
नेक्स्ट 1 मिनट में आप अपना सवाल पूछ सकते
हो। अदरवाइज हम सेशन को एंड करेंगे
क्योंकि आज थोड़ा सा सेशन थोड़ा सा हमारा
सेशन एक्सटेंड हो गया बिकॉज़ मैं नहीं
चाहता था कि जो ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग का
टॉपिक है उसको हम थोड़ा सा खींचे
ओके क्योंकि बोर हो जाते हैं बंदे यार
मुझे भी पता है डेढ़ घंटा पढ़ना इट इज एनफ
ओके
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
नोट्स का बाकी जो अगर वेब से उससे नहीं ले
सकते तो आई एम प्लानिंग आर्टिकल्स इनके
ऊपर मैं आर्टिकल्स प्लान कर रहा हूं। वहां
से आप पढ़ पाओगे मीडियम के। तो कोई डाउट
नहीं है।
कोई भी डाउट नहीं है। चलो फिर नेक्स्ट
सैटरडे संडे मिलते हैं।
कब कब पूछा? प्लीज आस्क मी वि क्वेश्चन?
गुड इवनिंग ब्रदर। उसके बाद वि क्वेश्चन
यू आर आस्किंग?
हां हाउ टू अवॉयड फिंगरप्रिंटिंग? मैं
नेक्स्ट क्लास में बता दूंगा। अगर आपको
चाहिए तो प्लीज जॉइ नेक्स्ट सैटरडे और
संडे में क्लासेस होंगे। मैं पूरा पीपीटी
के साथ बता दूंगा कौन-कौन सी टैक्टिक्स है
जिससे आप ब्राउज़र फिंगरप्रिंटिंग से बच
सकते हो। अवॉयड कर सकते हो।
चलिए फिर बाय-बाय। टेक केयर। गुड नाइट
एवरीवन। एंड अगले वीक मिलते हैं। सेम
सैटरडे और संडे दो लेक्चर लेके आएंगे।
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग और नेक्स्ट सेशन में हम
स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं। वैसे तो सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग
वो आपको खुद से करने पड़ेंगे रवि
बाकी मैं एक इस पे भी प्रैक्टिकल सोच रहा
हूं। सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का प्रैक्टिकल पेड
वेबिनार
आपको आईडिया मिल जाए शायद मे बी ओके एंड
बाय-ब गुड नाइट एवरीवन।